Wait for us to war record here.
Good morning everybody. Welcome
to the Open Cloth Shadow Intensive 2.0.
How's everybody doing? Type in the chat. Let me know.
How's everybody doing? Let me find the chat over here.
I'm so happy to be, I really appreciate the Zoom webinars.
Uh, but I absolutely love the Zoom meetings.
It's just more interactive. Good, good, good.
I see a lot of comments coming in. This is great.
Uh, good kind of nervous for today.
Nothing to be nervous about. Don't worry about it.
I, I got you handled.
Uh, we got some housekeeping and some things to fix.
We're gonna do that today. Um,
but first I wanted everybody to know
and acknowledge a couple people, uh,
that'll be here throughout the week.
Um, so the first, uh, you can see that I have one
of my lead, uh, uh, managing tech guys on the call.
We call him gmo. Uh, he is from Nepal.
Most of you, uh, know g and appreciate him.
Uh, we also have, uh, PNE who works right
beside him, also from Nepal.
My Nepal team is absolutely incredible.
Uh, and then we have Hannah who oversees, um,
the support desk.
And those three people are here
to help you today.
Alright? And they will be here, um, throughout the workshop
because this can get a little bit techie.
Uh, but I just want you guys to know that I'm kind
of the one, uh, steering the ship.
Um, but then these individuals are here to help you
and they will take you aside.
And if they need to log in, they will log in.
They will fix things throughout the whole entire workshop.
Does that make sense to everybody?
Is everybody crystal clear?
So you are in good hands, you are not on your own.
Uh, we will definitely get you fixed up. Okay?
So let me kind of share, uh, some of the notes
that I put together based off of what I was seeing,
um, this weekend.
And then I think everybody will be crystal clear on
what the overall goal and objective is here.
So lemme go ahead and share, uh, my screen.
Hold on just a second. Let me find that over there.
There it is. Zoom is always changing stuff on me.
Okay, so you guys should be seeing the open slide
for open cloth shadow intensive 2.0.
Is that what everybody's seeing?
Type in the chat, let me know. Yes, this is recorded.
You don't have to worry about that. Okay, good.
So, just a couple things before we actually dive in
and go very, very hands-on.
Just some housekeeping, right? So this is a daily call.
My plan is to do a 10:00 AM Pacific Standard time,
1:00 PM Eastern Standard Time.
Now, we just launched, we just wrapped up open class shadow
intensive 1.0.
I did not miss one single day.
We went 18 days straight except the weekend.
Now, if I need to change, I'll let you know
and it'll probably most likely be 2:00 PM
Pacific Standard Time.
So this session right here is five days
of onboarding, right?
So this is where we get you onboarded.
If that all goes well, then we will start
going more advanced with that.
But I wanna make sure that we get
everybody onboarded, right?
So that means that everybody's inside the members area,
we're gonna talk on that and everybody has their claw
launcher up and talking.
Okay? Um, so it's important, uh,
does everybody see where their hand is, uh, here on Zoom?
Does everybody see their hand?
I wanna make sure that everybody can see that. Okay?
You're gonna be using that throughout this
whole entire workshop.
And the team is trained that when the hand goes up,
they're gonna reach out to you.
Now, the biggest problem that we have when we do this,
the biggest problem we have is
that people don't see the message that my staff gives you.
They're pretty fast in messaging you.
So can everybody agree that if you put your hand up
that you will look for the message from the staff?
Can we all agree on that? Please? Yes.
If we can, you're gonna be in great shape. Okay?
So, uh, moment of truth.
Here's the thing, um, let me find the comments over here.
How many of you are inside the members area?
The members area looks just like this, yes or no? Okay?
If you are not in the members area,
the first thing I need you to do is I need you
to put your hand up
because we're gonna get you in the members area
right now, okay?
And my three staff members are getting ready
to take you aside.
They're gonna send you a message,
they're probably gonna wanna know
what email did you sign up with?
What email did you purchase with?
And then they're gonna go through
and they're gonna make sure that everybody on this call has
access to the members' area as they get you taken care of.
Then I want you to go ahead and lower your hand. Alright?
So let's see, uh, if I can find the hands over here.
Hold on a second. There we go. Alright, uh, g Money.
Say good morning to everybody. Would you please?
Hi everyone. Good morning.
Alright, so do you see these hands going up, G? Yeah,
I see them. Okay,
perfect. So guys, again, watch
for the private message from my team.
That's not too bad. I thought we're
gonna have a lot more than that.
Um, so we're gonna get you in here
and I'm gonna talk about this.
Um, but first I want you guys
to know something, right offhand.
Uh, a lot of the, um, um, Hannah
and I were working all weekend
and we were trying to help in support.
And I had people message me on, I had people texting me.
I had people messaging me on Telegram
and messaging me on WhatsApp, okay?
And, and we were doing everything we could
to get everybody onboarded.
I made a horrible assumption and it's my fault,
and I take responsibility.
A lot of the reasons why we had some issues with, uh,
onboarding with some people is
because when we initially set this up,
we set it up for a launch.
And I made the assumption that we had all new customers
and so on the thank you pages in the email, uh,
and everything else, I put a default password there for you.
So people were trying to log in with the default password,
even though they already had an existing
account in our members area.
Does that make sense? So that was a lot of the, uh,
uh, hold on a second.
Okay, there we go. That was a lot of the problems
that we encountered, okay?
And we're still encountering that right now.
Um, so we're gonna go through
and we're gonna get that fixed right now.
Um, yeah, and that was a problem too. Okay?
So these calls, guys, I'm gonna tell you right now, uh,
there's gonna be a lot of breakthroughs on these calls,
a lot of discoveries, uh, very, very interactive.
These calls are scheduled to go no longer than two hours,
but you guys are free to leave whenever you want to.
Does that make sense everybody?
You are not gonna hurt my feelings.
Uh, you'll be able to watch it in the replays area.
You'll be able to fast forward in the replays area.
You guys will be okay. All right?
And there's really nothing you can do to screw this up, um,
because we're gonna get the bare essentials in place.
Uh, you're gonna learn everything you need to learn to, uh,
be effective with open claw in your business.
It's gonna replace the things that you're already doing.
Uh, it's gonna be doing
things that you should have been doing.
And then, uh, the end result is
that you guys are gonna learn how
to start creating businesses, okay?
If you choose to continue, right now, we have some people
that are coming in on a very light level
and they're just trying this stuff out, okay?
So there is two different levels to come in on.
Now, what we're doing right now, guys,
this is the opening price point for our launch.
So we're testing out our delivery and, and the workshop
and how all this is gonna work before we do the launch,
before we have, you know,
a massive number of people coming in.
So if you came in on like the trial, on the preview,
then you're gonna go to this link right here, uh, Pacino,
that's the name of my open cloth.
Set up this link for you. Uh, if you are one
of our platinum buyers, then you're gonna
go to this link right here.
Is everybody crystal clear on this right now?
Is everybody crystal clear?
This over here is your $27 level.
This over here is a platinum buyer level.
Now, if you are one of my entourage Mastermind members,
if you are one of my mastermind members, you're gonna go
to your regular access
and you're gonna be able to access as well.
Okay? Does that make sense to everybody?
On a scale of one outta 10, how many of you are good now?
And yes, you can still get the upgrade, you need
to reach out to one of my team members.
Uh, they will get you upgraded and that's fine. Okay?
Now, I'm not gonna, uh, pressure you to upgrade
or anything else.
Uh, I'm gonna leave that up to you.
You're more than welcome to watch the presentation
and get clear what's included in the platinum package,
but I'm gonna do everything I can in these five days
that I have the spin with you to make sure
that you're successful, because I know these guys are in
good hands, but after five days,
I won't see you guys anymore.
Okay? So good. Um, so here's where we're at, guys.
Uh, we are gonna be in phase one,
which is the system activi activation, okay?
In the foundation. So making sure that number one,
we get you in the members area.
I'm gonna walk through that. And then number two,
I'm gonna show you exactly how to get set up with your, uh,
claw launcher, okay?
And I'm gonna walk through that.
There's some confusion there.
Some of it's my fault. I had a a video in there
that was wrong and people were still trying to log in, um,
to the VPS and everything.
You don't have to do that anymore. Okay?
So let me kind of cover that so everybody's crystal clear
and I just wanna make sure everybody
that needs help has their hands up.
Yes. If you need help, I want you to raise your hand
as you get resolved, I want you to put your hand down, okay?
We will not close the call with hands up.
So here's what I'm gonna do.
I am logged in as a mastermind member.
It doesn't really matter.
Uh, platinum members see the same thing.
Uh, what you're gonna see if you're a platinum member,
not if you're a $27 preview member,
but a platinum member is gonna see the open clause,
shadow intensive 1.0, and then we have the new 2.0.
Okay? So let me explain the difference.
When we did the 1.0, it was based off a theory.
We were gonna go out there and try this
thing and crack the code.
And I did it for 14 days with people.
And what we did was we went out there
and had you line up a VPS server
that you're probably most likely paying $24 a month for.
Okay? Well, we did, I don't know how many installs,
I think we did like over 500 installs.
We maxed out, we can't get the servers anymore.
And so that was good because that forced us to think
outside the box and come up with a new solution.
Okay? So everything that we did in 1.0, everything
that we did here was setting up your VPS server
and submitting your form,
and all this stuff is no longer applicable in 2.0.
Does that make sense to everybody?
That was part of 1.0 type of the chat.
Let me know if you understand. If you're new, you can kind
of tune me out right now, but I wanna make sure
that I'm taking care of the people
that are continuing their journey.
All right? So we don't have a VPS server anymore.
We don't submit a form.
My team is not doing the installs anymore.
If we go look at the onboarding prep,
you're still gonna set up your audio file,
you're still gonna create your profile,
you're gonna still gonna set up your agent email.
Uh, you're still gonna set up Telegram,
you're still gonna do your titanium API keys.
What you will no longer do, and a lot of the reason why is
because of the cost,
you will no longer set up your browser control
because as we're doing Claw Launcher, it is a Lennox server.
It does not use the browser.
And what we found out is we were going
through the workshop is you really don't need the browser.
It's too expensive, okay? And it's just kind of flaky.
All right? So if we come over here
to the onboarding follow up.
Now, what did we teach you?
Well, uh, we taught you to go
and, uh, remote in with remote desktop
on Windows on the Mac, uploading everything here, guys,
is no longer applicable with 2.0.
Does that make sense? Now, here's the great news,
and my team is already working on this for you.
How many of you feel like you have a pretty good foothold?
You, you, you set up your VPS, maybe you're using HY Next,
whatever you're using, you've been using your open claw,
you've been training it, and it has skills,
and, uh, you really don't wanna start over.
How many of you're filling
that good?
Because we're gonna provide the solution
where you are gonna be able to transfer all of that
to your claw launcher.
Does that make sense? So if you're continuing the journey
with me, just know that I got you covered.
We knew that we were, um, you know, pioneers kind
of blazing the path, kind of figuring things out as we go.
And I warned you guys at the very start that
where you start is not where you end up
and that it was going to improvise, it was gonna get better,
things were gonna change, okay?
So you can still get into 1.0, uh,
if you are a platinum member, let me go back over there
and let me click that again.
Uh, I, I think that, um, uh, the replays over here,
I think they were really, really good.
Do you guys think so? I think the
replays were really, really good.
And at the end of every single replay, uh, Pacino,
my open claw went and replay for you
and created a goal for you.
And a lot of these, if I could show you over here, uh,
we started doing this for you, if I come over here
where it says all resources, uh, you're gonna see
that the team has started going through
and putting all the skills that we built during 1.0.
Now everybody in 2.0 is also gonna get those skills,
as I promise you, but we're gonna be creating new
skills in 2.0.
All right? So all of my 1.0 members, all
of my mastermind members are you guys.
Now Crystal clear on, uh, what's going on
with the first workshop, time to chat.
Let me know if you got it. I wanna make
sure I'm taking care of you guys.
I don't want you to feel like you're, you're left behind.
And what do I do with all the work? Don't worry about it.
We got you. Okay?
And if you want to continue with Hynek,
it is a Windows based server
that you're probably paying $24 a month for, you can,
you can leave that alone for now.
You can come over here and do a new install.
You can move it over. It's whatever you wanna do, okay?
But now let's go open up 2.0
and let's explain what's going on here
because oh, wow, I didn't even see,
wow, you, this is incredible.
Uh, with 2.0, it's lot easier, okay?
And here's the reason why.
If I come over here, and if I open this up, what we're going
to do, and let me see if I can open this for you here.
Um, yeah, okay,
so if I open this up here, uh,
this is called Claw Launcher.
Okay? Now notice I am in here talking
to Claw Launcher, okay?
At least I think I am.
If I'm actually, let me do this in, uh, uh, Firefox.
Micro Chrome is having a lot of problems right now,
but uh, if I open this up here, yeah, okay,
let me go ahead and, uh, login.
If I can remember my login. Hold on a second.
I'm gonna show you what, uh, 2.0 is all about.
I think you guys are really gonna like this.
Uh, hold on a second. It's early for me.
Thank God that AI is able
to type correctly, right?
Okay, so this is now, is everybody seeing this right now?
This is Claw launcher. Can you guys see this?
Now notice there's no VPS,
there's no remote desktop,
there's no open Claw gateway, restart.
There's none of that stuff.
Now you just go log into Claw Launcher, okay?
Now, claw Launcher is
actually installed on your own CloudFlare account.
Does that make sense? I'll cover all that.
Amy, you're getting ahead of me.
Cloud Launcher is stalled on your own CloudFlare account.
Does everybody understand this right now?
And so you're gonna go through
and you're gonna set up a CloudFlare account.
They're gonna charge you $5 a month,
and you're gonna have 10 gigabytes of storage.
And from there, if you go over 10 gigabytes of storage,
then they're gonna charge you the usage
fees and you can go look at that.
It's very, very minimal.
This is a much better way
of doing this than using
A-A-V-P-S or hosting or anything else.
And CloudFlare clearly is the safest
environment you're ever gonna be on.
Okay? So this is the end goal.
This is where we wanna get you guys for the next few days.
So how do we do this?
Well, so we're over here on phase number one.
We'll talk about this when we get
to the end of this call today.
But let's look at how we can get you there. All right?
So the first thing is,
once we get everybody in the members' area, you're gonna go
through and you're gonna do these steps.
So step number one, you're gonna create a CloudFlare account
if you don't have one already, alright?
Pretty self-explanatory.
Step number two, you're gonna walk
through this short little video,
which is three minutes long,
and you're gonna learn how
to get what's called a CloudFlare token.
Now, there is four things that we are
after so
that we can create your claw launcher account for you.
There's four things. So you'll watch the video,
and then you'll come over here to the goal block.
You'll complete the goal, and then the next video will open.
Okay? Is everybody seeing this right now?
I just wanna make sure everybody is seeing this. Yes.
Okay, so you set up your CloudFlare, all right,
next you'll get your CloudFlare token.
Then you'll go get your CloudFlare account id.
Let's look how long this video is.
This video is also three minutes long.
These are very simple things,
and I broke them into individual goals.
This is where you're gonna go, um, not just yet.
I broke 'em into very individual goals so
that it's very easy for people to follow.
Okay? So you'll watch the video,
you'll do what's in the video,
and then we'll come over here.
This is the steps, and we go through here and good.
It's looking pretty good, right?
All these people are not having issues, which is great.
Okay? Now we'll come over here
and we'll look at this one right here,
which is getting your, uh, R two tokens.
Okay? So you'll again watch the video.
This one's less than three minutes.
You'll do the simple little steps
that I show in the video, okay?
You'll complete the goal, which is right here.
Very, very simple. Okay? Done.
So rare to have instruction videos. Good, good. I'm glad.
Are you guys liking this experience? By the way?
Are you liking this experience? Is it good?
It's good, yeah. Yeah.
We can get everybody the finish line this way. Okay?
So this is getting your R two tokens,
and then we come down here
and, uh, this is
where you're gonna set up your $5 account, okay?
And so this is where, um,
you've already entered your credit card details when you set
up your R two, now, you'll come over here,
you'll choose this paid plan,
and then you'll be on your $5 monthly account.
That's what it's gonna cost you, right?
So if I come through here, uh, yeah,
people are getting this done.
This is great. This is great. This is awesome. Okay?
I love it. Uh, look guys, I wanna give a big, uh, thank you.
Where a thank you is due.
Uh, you guys need to, uh, call out to G Money.
Uh, he is mainly, G
and PNE are the ones that set this up day and night.
They worked really, really hard on cracking the code
to figure out how you could have your own CloudFlare
installed so that you weren't hosed
by all the other people out there.
And there's so much that we're able to do
to simplify this whole thing, okay?
So you guys gotta give them a thank you. That was not me.
I didn't really have anything to do with it.
I just said, please, guys, find the solution
to help our people.
All right? So, uh, G pne,
I just wanna make sure you guys see your, you, you see
how appreciative everybody is?
Yeah, I see them. Okay, good, good.
So, um, and, and that was the whole goal, guys.
I wanted to open cloud to replace the automations
and stuff in our business, the pages, the links, so
that they could focus on creating incredible
solutions for our audiences.
Now, here's where everybody is, uh, confused.
Chad made the mistake
and did not have the right video there when you launched
your claw launcher.
And because of that, I had the original video there
where you were still, uh, logging into your VPS.
So I stopped last night, um,
after I talked to one of my, one of our members,
and he pointed out that that video still had the,
uh, the VPS.
I said, oh my God.
So I stopped everything last night, and I went
and shot this video for you.
That number one shows you how
to take those four things that you set up.
And you're gonna come in here,
you're gonna plug in your CloudFlare account, id,
your token, your R two access, your secret key.
So let me start from the beginning again, right?
So you come over here, you're gonna go to claw launcher.io,
you're gonna sign up for an account.
Now we will secure this,
but right now, I wanted to get you guys
going as fast as I can.
I ask that you please don't share any of this stuff, okay?
So you'll go here, you'll sign up for your account as soon
as you've signed up for your account,
you are gonna go ahead and log in.
You're gonna click on this button
that says Create a claw bot.
Once you do that, look at here, there's the four things
that you went and collected.
Is everybody seeing this right now?
Is everybody seeing this? So watch what happens.
You're gonna plug in those four things, okay?
So I open up my Evernote over here, notepad,
and I just copied them over here, and then I, I went ahead
and pasted them inside of there.
Uh, hold on a second.
Let me bring, uh, uh, where are you at, buddy?
Hold on a second. I forgot to bring somebody to the call.
Uh, okay, there we go. R two key. All right, there we go.
Let me, let me mute this.
I, I could do a better job walking through it, right?
So you plug in your, your, your CloudFlare account id,
your CloudFlare API token, your R two access key,
and your secret key, right?
You, you plug all these things in,
and then what's gonna happen is you're gonna click this
button that says Connect and deploy.
Is, is everybody seeing this right now?
Okay, so now watch, we're gonna go through,
it's gonna take a couple minutes
and I, I wish you guys would do this right now on the
call, okay?
So you can see it's gonna go through and it's gonna deploy,
and then you can add as many of these instances as you want.
But what you're gonna do is you're gonna click on Get
Started, okay?
Once you do that, it's gonna allow you to choose a plan.
Now in the near future, uh, there you go.
Keep dropping the link in the chat, that's great.
In the near future guys, we will charge for this,
but right now I'm just opening up to you guys
and letting you have lifetime access, $5 a month
between you and CloudFlare.
Is that cool with you guys? Does anybody have an issue with
that or should I start charging you?
That's all we're doing. Okay? So you'll go ahead.
Here's what I recommend. Even though G says
that this one's the most popular, come over here
and just grab the light one.
You got 10 gigabytes of stores, you're good here.
You come in on the light one, it's gonna be $5.
Now what's the difference? Well, you can see
that there's more CPU over here.
There's more ram over here.
So if you're techie, you know, whatever.
But most of you should just go choose the light one, okay?
Once you choose the light one,
here's what's gonna happen, okay?
You are gonna go through, you are gonna choose that one,
and you're gonna say, okay, let's continue.
And so now you're gonna come over here,
you're gonna name your claw, all right?
You can put it in a description
that's gonna help me in my daily task.
All right? Let me just show you that one more time. Okay?
So you'll go ahead and name your claw bot.
So, uh, you can see that I named this one The Godfather.
Is everybody seeing this right now?
So I named it the Godfather.
I'm gonna go ahead and put in my description.
And now where it says Connect your ai, you're gonna go ahead
and choose Anthro.
I would choose sonnet 4.5.
You go ahead and put your API key here, okay?
And once you do that, there's the API key.
You're gonna finish your setup
and now you're gonna see that it is gonna go set you up.
Come completely. Okay?
And so you'll wait for this,
it's gonna take about a minute and 15 seconds.
And then as soon as you're done with that,
it's gonna open up like this.
And you're gonna have all these messages up here
about pairing code.
Don't worry about it. It's gonna
clear up very, very quickly.
Once it clears up, it looks like this.
And from this point forward, you can say hello
and it's gonna start your onboarding process.
Is this making sense? Now here in a little bit,
I'm gonna ask you to raise your hand if you need help
with this part, but right now I wanna make sure
that we get everybody in the training area first.
So only put your hand up if you need
help in the training area.
And let me check in with G
and make sure, is everybody responding back to you G
or is there some people I can call out?
Yeah, not everyone's responding.
So, uh, if you guys take on the Zoom message,
you'll see our name pop up on the top.
If you can go there, there, there's gonna be a dm,
so please respond to us.
So look for your direct message on Zoom, guys.
Uh, they are reaching out to you, okay?
They're reaching out to you.
They wanna get you in the members' area.
Yeah. And if you guys are confused where that is, uh,
it would be the normal chat that you do on the call,
but on the top, there will be one new section popping
up as a new chat.
Yeah. So, uh, Bronson, Wayne, Headley, good to see you,
Wayne, Terry Huckabee, Craig Carlos, Donald Miller, uh,
Mike Linley, Ernest Hill, Mike Gillespie, Tony Green,
Sam Ney, Michelle Burt, James Code David Scarborough, uh,
Valerie McClain, Martin, Tom Hardwell, please, uh,
see if there's a message there from my team.
Don't nobody stress, uh, we are going
to get you logged in first, okay?
Um, and uh, I, I'm gonna tell you too,
if you're doing the claw launcher right now,
which I prefer you do for me,
I have a hard time with Chrome.
I am able to use Firefox. Okay?
So you might wanna try Firefox, uh, mark
and see, might wanna try maybe a new incognito browser.
Um, and that's okay.
Um, and so you wanna find the regular chat in Zoom.
It's there somewhere. And, uh, look
for a message from my team.
Uh, do you guys okay, look under more
or under reactions, okay?
So David Scarborough sees it.
Uh, is everybody seeing the message from the team?
Got Hannah's message, just a bit of a glitch, okay?
Uh, look for the message. It's there. Michelle sees it.
Alan sees it. Okay, we'll get everybody there.
Uh, you just gotta kind of hunt
around for Zoom a little bit.
Um, what I see, maybe somebody could put a screenshot
to show where those messages are.
Okay? Let's get past the members area stuff first
and then we'll start dealing with the techie stuff
with claw launcher, and there's gonna be some techie
stuff, okay?
There's gonna be some techie stuff.
So everybody relax, we will get you there.
There's a lot of you on the call
and we're trying to do the impossible.
Alright? So, um, I'm gonna go ahead
and show this while the team is helping everybody get,
um, set up.
So this video was not there,
but also when we come over here to the onboarding process,
this is actually the one that you were also missing.
So this is the one where I was showing you
that you were logged into the VPS.
So I stopped last night and went
and shot this one for you as fast as I could.
Okay? So this is gonna show you where you're gonna continue.
And now you can see that we're going
through the onboarding process inside of Claw Launcher.
Is everybody seeing this right now?
And you wanna go to, some people are putting
the wrong link in the chat.
You wanna go to App claw
launcher.io.
Guys, we're not trying to sell this right now.
All we're trying to do is take care of you guys.
Does that make sense? That's all.
So we don't have a sales page
app, we're not trying to do anything.
We're trying to take care of our audience first, right?
App Claw launcher, okay?
So we're focused, the team is focused on getting everybody
in the members area as they get you resolved,
please put your hand down, okay?
And, and that way the hands will start going away.
And gee, let me know how I can help with that, okay?
And you don't want to, yeah, we'll talk about what
to sign up for, but let me just kind of, uh,
finish this video first.
So this video here is a brand new video.
I, I shot it last night.
This will walk you through getting onboarded inside
of Claw Launcher, okay?
And I just pretty much redid
what we did in the first version.
The only difference is we can skip the browser control.
You can just type in skip, uh,
but you guys are gonna be able to watch this video.
Uh, you're gonna be able to get everything connected.
And then from there, uh, it says I'm locked
and loaded, right?
And that's okay. Where should we start?
So this is where we wanna get you to
for these few first few days.
We wanna have it where everybody is able to talk inside
of their claw launcher.
Okay? Does that make sense?
I wanna make sure that I'll start answering questions,
but I wanna make sure everybody is crystal clear on
what you should be looking for inside the member's area.
You'll set up your claw launcher,
and then once you have done all the onboarding prep,
you'll go through the onboarding process.
All right? So there's 15 people with their hands up.
Is there anything I can do to help you g?
Uh, not right now. We are just going through everybody.
Yeah. Some people are saying
that they can't see the message, which is unfortunate,
and I don't know what to do to help them.
Yeah, some of them are on the phone,
so I think it's difficult on the phone.
Maybe
They're on the phone.
Yeah. Um, and maybe the message
is not swinging out that way.
This is, this is the other thing you can do guys,
if you can't find the message, uh,
we're also monitoring support right now.
So you can either go to nicely support.com
or uh, you can go
to support@nicelysupport.com
and let them know that you're on the call right now.
Uh, if I, I mean, I prefer
to fix you while you're on the call,
but if, if that's not working,
if you can't find the message,
then put in a ticket right now
and let 'em know that you're on the call right now.
Let 'em know that you purchased a platinum
or you purchased a $27.
Make sure you tell 'em what the email address is
that you used, and then they will get you
fixed, okay?
And just have patience with the skies.
We will get everybody resolved right now.
So there's one of two things that you should be doing.
Number one, if you've already gone through
and you've already done all of the onboarding,
then why don't you head over to app
dot claw launcher.io.
You can watch this video here and go set it up.
Why don't you go set it up and let me see. Uh, good.
We already have some people that are set up. This is great.
Uh, just go ahead and, and do the steps
and then complete the goal.
Okay? That's fine. You can, you can do that
and then you can go ahead and go through the onboarding.
You guys can go ahead and do that. You don't have to wait.
Meanwhile, our core focus is getting everybody
inside the members area right now.
Okay? And again, some people put the link wrong,
so I'll put it in the chat again.
You're gonna go to app dot claw launcher.io,
not the root domain.
You're gonna go here, app
dot claw launcher.io.
Does everybody see that?
You can leave the webinar and come back, that's fine.
But the people that are ready to move forward, that,
that went through and did the steps, that's your next,
that's your next goal.
Go ahead and go through that onboarding process.
And, uh, we're mainly focused on, uh, the people that need
to get in the members' area.
So when they get you resolved in the members' area,
go ahead and put your hand down.
Okay? Now, uh, let me, um, find the questions over here.
Let me go through some of these questions
so I can buy the team some time
to get everybody in the members' area.
Um, okay.
Uh, your app doesn't, okay, hold on a second.
Let me see what's going on there.
That could be me doing that. Let me see. App course sprout.
Hold on a second. Let me go see what you're talking about.
I might have put the link wrong in there.
That would not surprise me.
So this is our course Sprout, which a lot
of you now have access to our course route.
Um, but if I look at step number one,
let's see, setting up your audio, creating your open claw,
setting up your claw launcher.
Let me look at this goal here.
Um, set up your, yep, it's wrong. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. That's where people are confused.
So we'll fix this right now.
App claw launcher.io. Okay, there we go.
So now we have it right in the gold block. Okay?
No big deal. All right, we'll save that. Okay?
Uh, and, and by the way, I could have told Pacino to go fix
that too, but, uh, all good.
All right, so now let's come over here.
Let's refresh this and let's make sure
that you guys have no confusion.
Okay, there we go. App claw launcher.io. Okay?
So watch the video and click that link
and go through the onboarding process
and then you'll be ready to, uh,
actually start doing this workshop.
Okay? Uh, let me see.
Hannah, are you doing good?
Yeah. Okay.
Just make sure you tell them
to put their hands down when they get resolved, okay? Okay.
Yeah. Um, alright.
Let me look at some of these questions here.
Trying to understand. We are with a whole,
let me start at the very, very top
'cause I haven't been answering questions.
Uh, LOL for once, being late to the game, paid off.
Didn't have that issue this morning yet. Good. Okay.
Um, hold on a second.
I'll have to scroll down, I guess.
Okay, let me find these questions.
Um, okay, uh, what's the link?
Okay, you guys got the link to Claw Launcher.
You now know that it's on a $5, uh, CloudFlare that you own.
Uh, do we have to create
or sign up for this call on your account?
Yes, you need to be creating the account right now.
Uh, and, and if, if you're still trying
to get in the members area, that's okay.
We'll get you in there. Uh, Chad, you
and your team are one in a million.
Thank you. What if you choose the middle one?
Uh, if you choose the middle one, I don't know, you might go
to like $6 a month instead of $5, right?
It's got more ram, it's got more storage,
but it's very, very cost effective.
You can change a plan whenever you want to.
Let's see, deploying the infrastructure.
Now, can you create one more than one agent?
Yes, you can, you can create more than
one instance inside of there.
Uh, oh, my, I gotta go over this again. Yep.
It's pretty simple though. Um, okay.
Need to access training area. They're getting you in there.
Do we need Claude? I'm playing.
I'm paying for a Google Gemini.
Uh, you can use Gemini,
but I'm gonna tell you right now, Gemini
causes a lot of problems.
Um, I would not use Gemini.
I would use Claude as your big thinker.
And then what's gonna happen is we're going
to install something called moonshot.ai,
which is gonna be 85% less than any
other model that you're gonna use.
Okay? Uh, let's see, where are they reaching out to us?
Okay, they're sending you a message.
If you're not getting a message,
submit a support ticket right now.
Um, this is so much better paying for Chad GPT can,
and we use this for Chad GPT.
The only thing you're gonna be able to use
with Chad GPT right now is Chad.
GPT uses something called whisper ai,
which will take your voice commands
and it will, um, uh, transcribe it so that open claw,
uh, knows what you're asking.
And so that's how you'll do audio files.
You'll use it with Chad GPT.
Other than that guys, Chad, GPT is pretty worthless inside
of open clock as of this time.
Okay? Brian says, I'm in the membership area. Yes.
Good, good. There's one, uh, let's see,
somebody else is in the membership area.
I see where Jordan, uh, let me put this on the screen.
Uh, you're pointing to something,
you're pointing to some chat.
Let me, let me just see if I can, uh,
put this up here for you guys real quick.
I saw where Jordan posted this image here.
Uh, I think he's showing you
that you can actually look at the chat over here.
There's gonna be a, a private message one.
So it says everyone new chat.
And then if G or Hannah
or somebody sent you a message, you would see it right here.
Okay? So I guess that's what it looks like on the phone.
So thank you for that, Jordan. That's great. Um, alright.
My hand went down. Good. Good, good, good.
I'm at the $5 setup so far. Good. That's good.
Uh, what if we're new, we don't need to start with 1.0. Yep.
If you're brand new, just go to the blue,
just go right to 2.0.
You don't need to worry about the red one
as you start getting your feet wet, guys,
especially if you're a platinum member
and you wanna go through some of the old workshops
'cause they're pretty incredible, you can,
but right now just start fresh with the new,
okay, just start with the blue.
Uh, I use free ai.
Is there one that has a great payment option available?
Uh, I don't know for sure. I don't know for sure.
Um, I know Kimmy 2.5 is gonna be the cheapest for you.
Let's see. Um, mark, did you get Firefox to work? Let's see.
Got Hannah's message. Just a bit of a glitch signing in.
Okay, she'll get you there. Wayne.
Does it take a while to set up account in CloudFlare
the an or cloud launcher?
The answer is no. You should be getting
set up right now on this call.
Is there any advantage if we use Claude instead of chat?
GPT? Yes chat.
GPT is a joke inside of Open Claw right now,
but um, guys, if I can help you understand this, um,
we are, we have spent a lot of money over $47,000
creating these skills, creating the software between me
and Karthik and, uh, Nick and some other people.
We spend a lot of money so
that we can just hand those over to you.
And when you have these skills,
when they're already trained, you get
to go run this model called Kim E 2.5,
which is pennies on the dollars 85% cheaper,
um, than Claude is.
So we built a whole entire course once,
it didn't even cost us a penny.
We saw it on the last workshop, right?
Um, so that's the goal.
The goal is to get everybody on Kimmy 2.5
and you only use the big thinker models like Claude four
point, Claude Opus 4.5,
or, uh, I, I would never use Opus right now.
I would use Claude Sonnet 4.5.
I use that to build software, to build apps,
to create products, create businesses.
Um, but you only use the big thinkers when you need to.
90% of the time you will be on a super ultra cheap model.
And the good news is it is leaning towards
going into free models.
And when we have the skills
and everything like we do, there'll become a point probably
in a couple months where you'll have free
AI doing everything for you.
Okay? Is that making sense to everybody? Uh, my goodness.
It says failing to connect to CloudFlare, but I did copy
and paste all the, okay, we'll look at it.
Ricardo. Um, trying to understand here.
Are we with CloudFlare
but it's not using a VPS,
the cloud bot is not connected to our personal computer.
Nope. You are not connected to your personal computer,
but you get to use it from your personal computer.
Okay? So it is hosted on your CloudFlare
and we set up a portal to access your CloudFlare, okay?
But ultimately you can use that, but you won't have to
because you'll be doing like I'm doing
and you'll be able to talk to it on Telegram
and you'll set all that up during the onboarding process.
Okay? Does that make sense? We'll get to the issues.
I'm gonna get g freed up here in a little bit
where we can get to the issues, uh,
with anything we're having with Claw Launcher.
I'm seeing some details there,
but, um, Chad, should we sign up with a new agent email,
uh, we created, you can or you can use the same agent email.
It's up to you. You can use the same API keys,
I assume you're probably gonna move everything over, right?
Carvin? Um, so you can use the same ones.
Uh, how do we sign up for an account if we are SC 1.0?
Same thing, same thing. Just create an account.
Uh, go through the onboarding process.
Like I just told Carbon, you can use your same credentials.
Um, yes,
you're very generous giving us this incredible tool.
Yep. Uh, let's see Ryan.
And we used email and pass that we have
for the members area to log into launcher.
No, you will create a new account right now.
You'll create that new account later on.
We'll have it to where it will create it for you
and it'll give you credentials.
But I wanna get you guys started right away.
I didn't want there to be a delay.
So you'll create your own account right now. Okay?
So whoever said which credential do we use
for uh, claw Launcher?
You're gonna create your own account just
like I showed you on the screen.
Okay? I'm in. What's the next step after signing in?
Well, you're gonna go through
and you're gonna give it the four things it's looking for.
It's looking for an account id, it's looking for tokens,
it's looking for R two, it's looking
for all those things, right?
So you're gonna plug that in
and it's going to install your claw launcher.
Uh, okay, we fixed the goal block.
My hand is up, but I'm not getting the message.
Okay, we'll look at that here in a minute.
I can't see a message to help me, but I use a link.
You show previous on the right side. I'm in.
I'm already in the members area. Good? Yes.
Put your hand down if you don't need help getting in the
members area, please put your hand down.
Okay? Uh, password Eloise, you set your own password.
Okay? I'm good for getting into Claw Launcher.
Had to create a new account. Yes.
Everybody will have to create a new account today.
Everybody will have to create a new account.
Uh, is this how it's gonna go every day?
No, but it will be initially,
it will be initially while we try
to get everybody in, right?
Um, I'm using the S two five Ultra better than
pc, but I see the message.
I keep getting a message saying, okay, we'll get there.
Where do I put the password? Yep, nicely support.com. Okay.
Is there any advantage? Okay, uh,
my Zoom is doing really strange things, never done before.
Had to jump off and back on.
So I missed about four minutes
of move from hi next to CloudFlare.
So Thomas, I assume you're in 1.0, all I was trying
to tell you is go ahead and get set up for your, um,
claw launcher if you want to.
And we're gonna do something special for you
to show you guys how to move everything over
to, uh, the new version.
Okay? Uh, remember the link is app
claw launcher.io.
We fixed it in the members area.
Um, let's see what to put in the password. Do you know that?
Now how much is a pro plan? We covered that.
Um, is there any advantage? Okay, we covered that.
Hold on a minute. Uh,
what are we subscribing to?
CloudFlare, I'm signing to my account.
You're subscribing to a plan
that's gonna cost you $5 a month.
That's it. Uh, shows it creates from the keys
and kicks me out to create claw bot,
then kick in, ask for philanthropic.
Okay? I'll have you guys
share your screen here a little bit.
Uh, can you put the link on the screen again?
How much is a pro plan?
Understand guys, we are not charging you
for any plan right now.
You're just choosing what storage
capacity you want on CloudFlare.
That's it. It's gonna be super
cheap no matter what you choose.
Um, there are some people behind.
We should all have finished at least the first five videos.
It's okay. It's okay.
Like nobody, nobody needs to stress this right now.
Just do the videos.
We, we will get everybody where they need to be. It's okay.
I went through this with 1.02 and it turned out just fine.
Okay? And we had no idea what we were doing with 1.0.
1.0 was really hard 'cause we were doing with servers
and open claw restarts and doctor fixes
and oh, it was really complicated compared to this.
Okay, so using CloudFlare, is that secure? Yes, it's secure.
You are not on your personal computer.
Uh, okay, CloudFlare, quick question.
If you have a CloudFlare account already, is it okay
to use your current account or for security?
Should you create a new CloudFlare account?
That's a good question.
I would think that you're okay
to use your existing CloudFlare account, right G?
Yeah, if you have an existing CloudFlare account,
just follow the steps to create
the token and you should be good.
There you go. Sherry. Oh, and by the way, happy birthday.
I saw that. Happy, happy, happy birthday Sherry.
Uh, Ricardo. So Claude need to make an account. Yes.
Follow the steps, Ricardo. Okay, good.
Yogi just posted a picture. He got it.
I see his, uh, claw launcher is installed.
All right, mark is in.
If you're inside of your claw launcher,
type in the chat, let me know.
Everybody say happy birthday to Miss Sherry Flannery.
Uh, let's see. I am at the create
claw lot, but I'm not sure.
Okay, watch the video. Unable to click. Okay.
Chad, can you explain where is the CloudFlare set up?
I think I did that, but I'll do it again. But it safe.
Is it safe? Is it safe? Is it safe?
Listen to me, this is as safe as it's going to be.
You're in a cloud flare container.
You are safe folks.
You're not in a computer, you're not on your pc.
Even though you're seeing it on your pc, you're safe.
It's ran, it's ran in your CloudFlare container. Okay?
Um, so I need to set up CloudFlare?
Yes, of course you gotta have a CloudFlare account.
I have OpenAI, but the API does not take the API key.
If you have CloudFlare, do you need to make a new account?
Yes. Well, if you have it already, you're good.
It's up to you, right? Do I need
to follow the steps on the members area
to learn how to get my R two code?
It's probably highly recommended that you do.
Alright, Sean says,
I got everything set up on Claw launcher.
Ricardo says, I set up Claw launcher with Gemini.
Can I modify it with C Claude? Yes, you can.
You can, you can, you can. Alright.
Uh, we'll look at that Jordan.
Try it, try it in a different browser maybe, right?
Uh, I missed about four minutes.
What do I do with my high next account?
Uh, well this is gonna be a lot cheaper, a lot more secure,
a lot easier for you.
Um, but it's up to you what you wanna do, okay?
Uh, okay, let me try this.
I'm struggling with the API follow instruction,
but gives me air red box at the bottom.
Okay? The red box at the bottom, that little bar
that pops up on CloudFlare is probably most likely popping
up because you haven't confirmed your email.
So CloudFlare has sent you an email.
You need to click on the link in the email
to confirm your account
and then you should not see that red bar anymore.
There's actually an error message
that's hidden over there, but you gotta find it.
Okay? Uh, let's see.
You got air invalid CF token
or account could not route, blah blah blah, blah, blah.
Uh, okay, I'm getting to the point where we're gonna be able
to put hands up for this stuff too.
Uh, what do I buy on CloudFlare? R two bucket?
Follow the videos. You guys gotta follow the videos.
There are three minute videos.
How many claw bots pacinos can we set up?
Uh, you can set up as many as you want to.
You're just, you're just paying CloudFlare for the space
and, and ram and usage and all that good stuff.
Okay? Um,
Um, about that Chad, um, since it's the beginning
and the CloudFlare is just on the light version,
I think you can create max up to like three for now.
Okay, three. So the light version has three.
Do we have that in that pricing table?
No, not yet, but, uh, it's the CloudFlare limit.
So you, you can try act most three.
Okay, so they don't, you don't,
you guys don't need three right now.
You need one, right? We'll get there.
I mean, claw launcher, it says the light plan is $10.
Light plan should be $5.
I don't know where it would say $10.
It should be five, right? G?
Yeah. What is the difference
between a pro and um, the difference between a pro
and a bundle?
I pay for bundle. So look, we are not doing anything.
We are not charging you anything.
Those three plans are how big you want
to have with CloudFlare.
What I recommend everybody do is just start with the light.
The people that are having trouble are the people
that have not gone through the videos and that's okay.
I told you it's gonna be okay. But now
I'm telling you, go through the videos.
Stop. There are two to three minute videos.
Go through the videos, one little goal for each video.
You'll complete the goal block down below,
and then we're gonna be able to get you there, right?
Uh, okay in the cloud launcher and chat started with my bot.
Good. I'm not getting any response to my claw launcher,
probably most likely because it's an API key issue.
And we're gonna address that in a minute.
I created a CloudFlare Key last night
and I thought I copied onto my note add.
But do I go back?
Yeah, you have to create a new, uh, you, uh,
yeah, you have to create a new key.
You have to go create a new key.
I don't think they'll let you copy it for safety reasons.
Um, I go app.law launcher.io login.
I use my email for joining and password,
but it shows red reply.
Uh, red reply
inside a CloudFlare means you haven't confirmed your email
address, right?
So check your email first Brandon,
see if there's a confirmation there.
Uh, CloudFlare container is similar to a VPS.
It's better with a VPS.
In order to access your VPS, you have
to use like remote desktop.
And then if you're a Mac user, you have
to have some special app to do it.
This, you don't have to, right?
With this one here, uh, you guys will be able
to just log into your claw launcher
and you'll be able to run your open claw from there.
But like I said, the majority of the time,
what we're gonna be doing during the workshop is we're gonna
be doing it on Telegram.
Okay? Uh, what Kimmy account do you recommend we set up?
I recommend that you don't do anything with Kimmy yet,
but we'll be using 2.5.
Okay? All right. So we're down to, uh, eight hands.
If you have been resolved,
can you please put your hand down,
which means we got seven of you.
We're halfway there. We got seven
of you in the member's area.
So please put your hand down if we have you resolved.
Uh, if I look at this right now,
let me just see the attendees.
Uh, hold on a minute.
And this is how, uh, we do this
to make sure nobody gets left behind.
So we have Terry Huckabee, Mike Gillespie,
David Scarborough, Doug Starks, Richard Hall, Frank E,
Brian and Ricardo.
We're down to you guys.
Uh, have, have all of you guys checked your messages.
If any of you have been resolved, please put your hand down.
There goes another one down. Good.
So I got three team members that are going through right now
to get you guys taken care of, get you onboarded completely.
There goes another one down
and Then as soon as we get these hands down guys,
I'm gonna ask people to put their hands up again for any
of the tech issues with Claw Launcher.
Does everybody understand this right now?
Super, super challenging
to help this many people, but we're gonna get there.
Uh, okay. Uh, I got access to the portal, so I will do more
after watching the training.
Good? Good, good, good, good, good. Okay.
Do we need a paid Claude account? Okay. Good question.
I need to put that in the goal video. All right.
So, um, everybody from 1.0 already knows this.
If you're new, what's gonna happen is when you fund Claude,
uh, Claude wants you to spend at least $40 with them
so that you can get to what's called tier two.
Okay? If you're not on tier two,
then what's gonna happen is you're gonna be experiencing
these token limits and things hitting,
and you're gonna be like, Hey, I keep getting this error
about some token limit.
Yeah, it's right.
Claude wants you to be at least at tier two
to get past those limits.
Okay? Does that make sense?
I wanna sh but may, but,
but understand this guys, the majority
of the time you are going to be on Kimmy 2.5,
which is gonna cost you hardly anything.
Okay? Um, all right. Let's see.
What is the difference between the pro?
Okay, I already told you that it's just
more space, more ram.
Uh, do we sign up for an account if we're sc it's up to you.
Uh, let's see, Sam, I think Sam, we got you resolved. Yeah.
Uh, okay, hold on a second.
I lost my spot. I'm in the launcher. Good, good, good.
Yes, CloudFlare is secure.
I think everybody understands that now. Okay.
And all we have to do guys, is get past the setup.
We just gotta get past the setup.
Once we do, this'll be smooth sailing, right?
Um, okay, I'm struggling with a P. Okay?
We know the red box now is you need
to verify your CloudFlare account.
We talked about in the light version, you get
to set up three, okay?
Uh, okay. The plan should not be $10. Should be five.
Okay? Good, good, good, good.
Lots of birthday, lots of birthday messages.
Uh, what's the difference between pro?
Okay, we talked about that. Understand correctly,
if I started Shadow 1.0
and I bought the server from High next, already installed it
by your support, however,
I'm running behind and haven't started.
Best to just cancel high. Next.
Yeah, save yourself 24 bucks a month. Go down to five.
Uh, Valerie says, I think I got my
launcher set up and fixed.
Congratulations, Valerie. That is amazing.
Steve says, having trouble understanding
the actual tokens to use.
I have saved the R two CloudFlare token or cloud account id.
You need to save four things. Watch the video, Steve.
Uh, if my cloud account is under another email,
will it require me to set up a new account?
No. Cheryl, you can use the same account.
Uh, why would we want more than one? I don't know.
Different businesses, whatever.
I don't think we should even talk
about having more than one.
Okay? When, uh, we, we just wanna get everybody one, right?
Let's get everybody one first. Uh, I'm at CloudFlare.
It's not asking for money. It's sent me straight to a page
that says, uh, my email account.
Well, you're gonna sign up for CloudFlare first,
then you're gonna go through the steps in the video.
As you go through those steps,
it will ask you when you set up your R two
to enter a credit card, okay?
I'm in my cloud. API key was the issue,
created a new one and started working.
Congratulations, Martin.
Ricardo says, so we need
to purchase a pro account on Claude.
Yes you do. I mean, uh, no, no, no, no, no.
You don't need to purchase a, uh, a pro account.
You need to follow the video and get the API key
and then fund your API key.
And I want you to fund at least $40 when you can so
that you're on tier two.
Uh, let's see. I'm in claw launch every
time I refresh the claw launch.
Your price increases from 10 to 19 a month.
Don't worry about that. We'll figure out what that is.
I have not seen that yet, but you're your look.
You did not enter a credit card on Claw Launcher.
Does that make sense? You entered your
credit card on CloudFlare.
It has nothing to do with Claw Launcher, nothing to do
with us Claw Launcher is just an installer,
guys, that's all it is.
You don't have a,
you don't have a credit card on file with us, okay?
It's just between you and CloudFlare.
If you did the light, you're at five bucks a month, okay?
Um, okay, please.
Uh, Hannah says, please raise your hand
if you have members area access issues.
We're down to six of you, so that's good.
Um, we should make Hannah an admin too.
Gee, Hannah and pne, if you can, if they're not already.
Yeah, both of them are admins. Yeah. Okay.
And also, also, guys, if you have any questions like what
to do on the next step, please just go through the course
so you have the detailed, uh, explanation on what to do.
If you have problem, like you already,
you're already on the claw answer
and you're having some problem, like take problems.
You can text me directly on the Zoom,
but, uh, don't raise your hand
and, uh, we are just trying to resolve the members there.
Okay? Did you guys hear that?
He said that if you're having issues, G is a multitasker.
Chad is not a multitasker,
but if you're having issues with claw launcher, uh,
like it's in a circle
or something with an API key,
what he said is you can send him a message
directly right now, but don't raise your hand yet.
'cause we're still trying to get the five
people in the members area.
Uh, yep, we have two, we're down to five.
We're still trying to get everybody in the members area.
Okay? And now we're down to four,
and then we can focus on the claw launcher.
Does that make sense to everybody? Uh, okay.
Can you start a new CloudFlare under a different email?
Yes, you can if you want to.
I am to the titanium step in the training videos.
I need to put all the API keys
before going into the members' area.
No, no, you can go in the members' area right now.
I would assume that the members' area is
what you're watching the videos, right?
Uh, which API token do I use outta CloudFlare? Explain.
Yeah. Terry, go through the videos.
I I, I'm not trying to sound like a jerk,
but they're three minute, no fluff, no hype, no story.
Just do this, right?
And, and it is so much easier to just do that than try
to ask people advice on the call, okay?
Just, just take your time, go through the videos
and if you wanna leave the call and go through the videos
and get this done and come back
to the call, that's okay too.
We're gonna spend this call making sure everybody is
onboarded, okay?
Uh, Cheryl, $40 a month? No, not $40 a month.
If you're talking about the Claude funding on your API key
$40 total, not monthly.
Not monthly. This is your API key, right?
You go to platform.claude.com I think.
I think that's what it is. And when you set up your API key,
you're gonna fund it.
And as soon as you have funded $40, not $40 a month,
but $40, then you'll be on tier two.
And when you click on
limits, I'll show you this here in a minute.
When you click on limits, it'll
tell you the tier that you're on.
Okay? You wanna be a tier two so you don't have any
of the limit issues.
How do you fix the Red Bar issue? I go to create token.
Uh, yeah, you gotta verify your email address.
Go look at your email.
CloudFlare has sent you an email address.
Why do we set up with Claude at
$40 if we're gonna use Kimmy?
Claude is your big thinker when you guys start building
software, uh, when you, um,
start training on your own skills,
you are gonna wanna have the big thinkers.
And Claude Sonnet 4.5 is my big thinker.
I don't use Opus anymore. Opus was expensive.
But I do use sonnet when I'm training on skills and stuff.
Once we have the skills, once we have Theron jobs,
you'll get this thing where it's trained how you want it.
Let Kimmy 2.5 run it automatically.
You're gonna do two things.
You're gonna either do what we call on demand,
where we do like four slash pop link four slash sales page
slash broadcast.
Those are on demands.
Kimmy 2.5 can do that,
or you're gonna set everything up on Aron job
and that's where things are set to run at certain intervals,
certain times Kimmy 2.5 can do that too.
So your big thinkers are when the big dogs come out
to do the training or to build the software, okay?
Most of the time you're not gonna use that. Alright?
Um, which credential do we use for Claw Launcher? Yep.
Create your own account. I'm in. Okay, good.
Good, good, good. That works. Okay, I think we're down.
Let me go down to the very, very bottom.
Uh, I did all the courses last night.
That's what I keep trying to tell you,
but the names that he's using for some of these tokens
or other things are different than
what they were last night.
I have all four of the things that we're supposed to do.
I'm just trying to make sure I put them in a correct place.
I went through the videos and I used that information.
But some of the terminology that you're using where
the terminology I'm using where in the goal block
on the slide just now, where, tell me specifically
where the conflict is so I can get that resolved.
It's valuable feedback,
but tell me where so I can get it resolved.
Uh, if we set up our accounting claw launcher,
but we wanna change the email, can it be done?
I think so. We'll ask G when he gets freed up for a minute.
He is definitely the brains behind that.
Um, okay.
If the goal block doesn't match, okay, hold on a second.
I didn't create the goal blocks myself.
So let me, let me go look at the goal blocks guys.
Hold on a second. Pne, do me a favor.
Can you do me a favor real quick?
Make sure that goal block matches
where you plug those four pieces of information in.
Can you make sure those match?
That's where people are confused.
Yeah. Okay.
He'll go, he'll go make sure those match guys
and then we'll be, we'll be clear.
Uh, Elaine says, woo-hoo, my open claw is live.
Steve, you gotta watch a video.
I know for a fact that I show you how to get the R two key
R two tokens, right?
Not our two key, but our two tokens to understand correctly.
If I started Shadow 1.0 and I bought server from High next
and I already installed by your support, running
behind it would be best.
Yeah, cancel it. Cancel it.
If you didn't do anything, cancel it.
Just start over, start over. You have a fresh start today.
You have a fresh start today with a whole new, uh, agenda.
We cracked the code now everything's different.
Just start over. You'll be good, you'll be good.
Uh, did you do a video on setting up API for Claude?
Yes, I did. I did as part of the onboarding process.
Okay, so as soon as, uh, PNE fixes those goal blocks,
uh, we'll go look at that.
When I'm in the open cloud members area, front page,
should I forget the big red, open claw intensive big icon
and concentrate on the big blue?
Yes. So here's what I'm gonna do.
Um, I'm gonna find a way right now.
Uh, I'm going to kill it for a minute.
I'm gonna kill the red one.
All you see now is the blue one, okay?
If you're a mastermind member,
I left the red one open, right?
So all you see is the blue one.
Now, right now there's no question.
Just go through the blue one.
Just go through the blue one, okay?
Uh, David Scarborough, Richard Hall, Frank E. James Co.
James, I thought we got you resolved.
I thought you got in the members area.
Aren't you a mastermind member?
Then go log into your mastermind members area.
Yeah, it's there. Go look.
They're both, well, they're both there.
One and two, go look and then we can get your hand down.
All right. Um, so Paul, Dean, Frankie and David Scarborough.
Sorry Chad, I can't find the cloud setup.
All right, let me just make sure, hold on a second.
Let me log in. I'll show you.
Uh, let's see.
Onboarding, prep, audio file, telegram, uh,
CloudFlare account R two tokens, setting up audio file.
Titanium API key. Hold on a minute.
Nothing to be sorry about.
It could have been in the first one.
So let me just see real quick.
It is been kind of confusing transitioning from
one to the next guys.
Now I know why nobody else is out there
trying to do this right now.
Um, but let me see. Setting up windows.
Okay, onboarding, prep, setting up audio files.
Okay, hold on a second. It should have been in the
very first one.
Create your CloudFlare. Okay, hold on a second.
Setting up Windows VPS Secure.
Okay, you know what, hold on just a minute,
I'm gonna get you fixed up.
It was in the red one. It wasn't in the blue one.
So let me put that in the blue one for you.
Gimme just a second and I'll get that done.
So open this guy up, open call.
Okay, so, um, I'm gonna make that part of the onboarding.
Okay? Hold on a second.
You're gonna see it in just a second.
Okay?
We'll get that in there.
You guys should be doing the steps right now
for claw launcher.
All in all, I'm actually pretty happy with
how it's going guys, believe it
or not, I am very, very happy how this is going.
Okay, so here we go. I'm gonna put this here.
Claude Anthropic, API key.
And then we'll go ahead and do like this.
And then I'll go ahead and put this video here.
Add new video
and API key.
Okay, here we go.
And video and an
Claude, where are you at?
There it is insert. Okay, can you see that video?
Now inside of onboarding prep, let me share my screen.
Um, hold on a second. Share two.
Okay, so if I come over here, if I go into the blue one,
okay, so the blue one's the same for everybody.
So I come inside of here
and where you go to onboarding prep, it's right here.
Do you see it now? Do you guys see it?
There's the API key video
and that that'll walk you through that wrong screen.
Okay? Hold on a second. Share screen, share one.
Let's try again. All right, so again,
you're in the blue one, okay?
And when you come over here
to onboarding Prep, it's right here.
It's that first video. Got it.
So if you don't, if you don't know how
to set up your anthropic API Key, just remember to fund it,
um, $40.
And let me see if I can show you why.
If we go to platform.claude.com
and if we come over here to API Keys, uh,
here's the API keys.
And if I click on limits, you're gonna see
that I'm tier four.
Does everybody know what their tier is for Claude?
Type in the chat. Let me know if you got it.
You wanna be at least tier two
so you don't hit those rate limits.
So Thomas is two, mark is two.
The more you spend the higher it goes up.
Chris is two tier two. Yep.
And all you gotta do is make sure you spend 40
bucks with Claude.
Claude is gonna be your big thinker, guys for 2026.
It's gonna be the year of Claude.
So you're gonna log into platform.claude.com.
This is where you would've set up your API key.
And then when you click on Limits over here, you can see
that you're gonna see your limit.
See this right here, you're gonna spend 40 bucks.
It'll jump up to tier two.
It is a one time funding.
It is a one time funding of $40.
It's not $40 a month. It's not $40 continuously.
Just one time. Hold on, James, I'm checking.
Uh, entourage. No, you should have both.
James, if you're
inside the mastermind members entourage
mastermind.org/members.
You should see both. You should see
the blue one and the red one.
Can I get other, uh, mastermind members to confirm that?
All right, let me see how we're doing with the hands.
We're down to two hands. We got Paul, Dean and FIAs.
So, uh, let me check in with G.
What's the status on these two?
I think Hannah and Brene are, uh, contacting.
Okay. And then we have Terry
Huckabee that just put his hand up.
All right. Um, Hannah, are you on Paul, Dean and FIAs,
Ms.
Hannah?
Uh, Paul is not responding.
Paul, can you respond to her? Paul?
And how about FIAs?
Yeah, I'm taking with you. I think he's with Brene.
Okay, so FIAs is being handled by pne.
Paul Dean, Paul Dean calling once, calling twice.
Can you look for a message from Hannah?
She's trying to get you set up.
And then what's gonna happen, guys,
we're gonna get these hands down
and then we're gonna put some more hands up
and deal with all the technical obstacles
that we have going on, uh, with Claw Launcher, okay?
Is, is everybody good? Now?
I totally expected this, by the way,
totally expected this, right?
We have so many tiers we're relying on JBZ.
It's firing off IPNs, it's not firing off. IPNs.
Different levels. People coming over here from phase one
to phase two, new people coming in, trial, people coming in.
This is the only way to get people there, right?
So don't put your hand up.
Only put your hand up if you're still trying
to get in the members area,
we need to get in the members area.
In the meantime, if you can message G uh,
you can see right there, he's at the top.
He is a host, G-A-U-R-A-V.
Message him personally if you're having an issue
with Claw Launcher and he can get you set up.
Okay? Does that make sense?
So like Terry, you say I'm hung up at Connect ai.
Message G, message g Ricardo says, I'm on tier one.
How do I go to tier two? Spend 40 bucks. Spend 40 bucks?
It'll happen automatically. It's very complex.
Yeah, Elaine, try, try, try being me.
Just added $40 credit
and Claude, uh, it now set me to tier one under limits.
It will set you to tier two. You just gotta keep refreshing.
It will set you at tier two.
Uh, how long after creating the first claw
before it shows in the account, everything intercepted
and still shows, create your first claw message, G.
He will help you will, uh, you have to be at $40
to be at tier two, correct?
You talked about Kimmy skills and other things.
If you were on the $27 plan,
are you gonna show us how to add them later?
Yes. Yes, we will. We will cover Kimmy probably tomorrow.
'cause I wanna make sure, I wanna make sure
that we get you guys there, right?
Uh, how do we connect to G?
You can just go ahead and hit his name.
He's a host and send him a pm. Send him a pm.
Okay? Uh, Sam says,
with all this chaos, you're doing a great job.
It ain't my first radio rodeo buddy. I've done this before.
So you can see where G is saying, I'm here guys.
Do you see him saying, I'm here.
If you have a tech obstacle right now with um, um, uh,
claw Launcher, then, then message him.
And then we're gonna start sharing some of those issues.
Okay? But I just wanna make sure, uh,
did Paul Dean respond yet?
Hannah?
No, not yet. Okay.
And FIAs is being dealt with by, uh, pne.
And we have Terry Huckabee, Ernest Hill,
and Frank e Do you see them?
I assume they're having membership issues too.
So Elaine is on tier two. Okay, good.
Uh, Paul says he sent a message,
so maybe you can check Hannah.
I think it's so stupid that I have
to coordinate getting Zoom to work with messages.
That's the biggest challenge we have here, right?
Uh, once I added the $40 in Claude, it now allows me to chat
with Claude Launcher.
Booya. There you go. You are up and going.
How many of you got your claw launcher installed?
Let's be some, let's, let's have some encouraging news here.
Who has their claw launcher installed in talking?
Anybody time to chat. Lemme know if you're there.
So Brian is there. Ricardo was there. Elaine is there.
Elaine is in the process. Uh, meme. Kenny John says perfect.
Martin is there, uh, Thomas is there.
Mike Gillespie is there. Sean? Uh, okay. Sean, message G.
Uh, Capel, good to see you. Capel.
Ricardo is on tier two of Claude. Good.
Frank, got it installed. Uh, LaShaun almost ready?
Says soon. Craig is in the process, guys.
We're making progress. Yeah, we're making progress.
This is good. This is, this is exciting for me
because when you can come in
and have an explosion, like I knew we were going
to Connie's, like, you know what,
I'm gonna go get my nails done
'cause I know you're gonna be busy today.
Uh, we're we're gonna, we're gonna get to the finish line,
we're gonna get to the finish line.
I logged in the claw launcher,
but I can't get it to respond to anything, okay?
We know what that is. Uh, message g Richard,
if you would please, uh,
if we set up our account in Claw Launcher,
but we want to change email message G Carla,
I don't know that answer yet.
Uh, I keep getting this message
and sending out my claw launcher.
Okay, message G Doug, message G.
Sorry G, I'm putting you on the spot buddy.
Here's what I'm hoping, I'm hoping
that you'll identify all these issues
and then make me look super,
super smart when I share my screen.
Can we do that?
Uh, let's see.
Tony Green. When I log in the membership, it looks like 1.0.
I don't see 2.0.
Uh, put your hand up, Tony, they'll help you.
We'll see what that's about. Uh, message G.
Yeah, GG is the man. We call him G Money.
He is definitely the,
the most brilliant person on this call.
And then PNE is right, right behind them.
They make me look smart.
I'm actually not all that smart guys. I'm just entertaining.
Right? G is the Yoda.
There you go G You don't mind that, do you?
You don't mind being the Yoda, right?
No, he is like, I can think
of worse, right?
Okay, good, good, good, good, good, good.
Okay, we're getting everybody there.
We're down to a few hands now. Another one just went up.
Alright, wanna get everybody in the members area, okay?
And if you have problems, uh, then message G,
keep asking the questions.
Keep asking the questions.
I still don't get the name of G here in the chat.
It is G-A-U-R-A-V av, right?
But we just call him G Money, but his name is av, right?
Tommy says you make a great front man. I am a circus monkey.
So Elaine, there you go. Av, av, av.
Can everybody type in the chat?
AV say thank you, AV, thank you Av.
He is the one that built this incredible platform, not me.
He is the one that built it.
Uh, hi G, I'm logged into claw launcher
but can't get it to respond.
Okay, if you can send him a message, Richard,
he can keep track of it, right?
He can keep track of it.
Uh, do I need to sign up first
before I can join App Claw launcher or your system?
Yes. Sign up for an account, please. Bronson.
And I show that in the video,
so please sign up for an account.
Please, please, please, please, please.
That would be great if you would do that.
Uh, what other questions guys?
Instead of activate R two order,
summary page on CloudFlare, I get this page.
Okay? Uh, yeah, message that to him.
Uh, mark if you would,
because he can keep track of the private messages, uh,
better than the public ones.
Okay, perfect. Perfect, perfect, perfect.
Uh, Hannah, it looks like we got him taken care of.
Yeah, we got Paul Dean taken care of.
Yeah, I am in message with him.
Good job. Okay.
Uh, is there anybody, um, pne,
did we get those goal blocks taken care of?
Yeah, when I check it was good.
Oh, it was good. Yeah,
Somewhere there's a conflict,
so I don't know where the conflict is.
Is it matching everything perfectly
that we pull from CloudFlare?
Yeah. Uh, okay, in the video it says create bucket.
Hold on a second. Well, you know,
CloudFlare is always changing stuff too.
Uh, yeah, but it says create bucket up in the top right
corner, right in the video it says Create bucket.
I think that's correct. Yeah. Create bucket.
That looks correct to me. Uh, okay.
Gee, how do we message you?
You should just be able to click on
his link and send a message.
You should just be able to click
on that link and send a message.
Okay? What other questions guys?
What other questions I'm gonna show you again,
I'm gonna do a recap again
'cause I wanna get everybody to the finish line today.
I wanna get everybody to the finish line, okay?
If you're inside the blue area, all right?
The first thing you do is you come over here to the setup.
If you don't have a CloudFlare account,
you're gonna create a CloudFlare account.
You are gonna create your CloudFlare token.
You are gonna create your CloudFlare account id,
you're gonna get your R two token.
You're gonna get set up with a $5 worker.
This is the contract between you and CloudFlare.
And then I'm gonna show you,
hopefully it's right in the video.
And click this. Well, it has to be right in the video.
Hold on, this is the one.
So we have look, CloudFlare account id,
CloudFlare API token, R two access key
R two Secret Access Key.
Okay? So those four things are what we need to connect our,
uh, claw launcher to CloudFlare.
So if we come over here and let's open this up.
If we look at the goal, you have your CloudFlare account
token, your CloudFlare API token,
your R two access key id.
Hold on, maybe that's the one.
No R two access key id. Hold on a second.
Was the top one token? Yeah. And then R two secret key.
And this is R two secret key.
So these four things right here are matching the goal block.
So I'm not quite sure
where people are confused, but we'll figure it out.
So these four things right here, what you need,
and then you're going to paste 'em in here.
So anybody that hasn't done this yet, anybody
that hasn't done this yet, that's what you're gonna do.
Okay? So once you do that,
you're all set up on CloudFlare, okay?
And you just follow the simple little steps here.
And I could see that yes, people are doing it.
Good, good, good, good, good, good, good.
Um, I'd be,
I'd be really surprised if we didn't have more than that.
Let me refresh this. Hold on a second. Let me see. Open.
Done, done, done.
Make sure you guys complete the goal block.
'cause this is how we tell if we're being
effective with our training or not.
Come down here and tell me
that you completed your goal block.
Please. Can you guys do that?
'cause I've seen way more than nine people launch their, um,
their, uh, open cloud, their,
their claw launcher on the call.
So make sure you complete this goal block. Okay?
So you'll, you'll watch this video, you'll launch that,
and then what's gonna happen is if we go back over here
to the onboarding prep, these are all things
that you're gonna need for your onboarding.
And then here's the video that shows that you're onboarding
inside of Claw Launcher.
All right, good stuff.
Um, hey Chad Lake to the party trying to catch up.
Should there be a second email with login info?
I don't know what that means. Logging info to the course.
Do you have access to the course? Marty?
You should have got an email from your members access.
Did you get that? Uh, I need
to get past this cloud launcher error message.
Uh, Doug Message G. Need a new account.
I still can't find G's message link. That's crazy, man.
Like you just click on his name and send him a message.
You just click on his name
and send him a message on step six on claw lunch.
I've been in a queue a lot.
Is there anything we could do that could be internet,
could be bandwidth issue?
I don't know. Uh, working on it. Multitasking.
Uh, can you repeat from the start?
I'm kind of doing that already. Gotta admit this is a blast.
Folks having fun and smiling. Yeah, me too. Uh, let's see.
Bronson says, is it actually sign up CloudFlare
first and get all the info?
Yes. You ha you have to sign up
to CloudFlare first.
Uh, Marty, did you just sign up today?
If so, can you put your hand up so
that we can see what's going on with your members area?
You should have gotten an email with access details.
I'd really like to pinpoint that issue.
Um, okay, perfect. He's got his hands up.
Uh, need a new accounting.
CloudFlare look, if you have an existing
account, you're good.
Okay? If you don't have an account, go create an account.
Okay? What if we already have one from the shadow?
You're fine. Just one email, first link.
Need to log in, don't have credentials.
You should have got another one.
Can you just check your spam, check your promotions,
Marty, just to make sure.
Uh, if not, then put your hand up,
your hands up, they'll help you.
Okay? Am I getting ahead? I get this message.
Step four, browser extension, click,
skip Elaine, click skip.
We'll talk about why we're skipping the
browser here in a minute.
Uh, Mike says, watching the tutorial videos
is extra helpful.
So it's not everybody's fault,
but the people that are struggling are
the ones that didn't watch the videos.
You guys are seeing that, right?
And it's not everybody's fault.
Some people didn't has access to the members area.
That was not their fault. But, um, it's okay.
We're we're gonna, we're gonna get everybody there.
Now here's the thing, I'm gonna set this up.
Is there anybody that is thinking
that they're gonna go out there
and they're, oh good, you found it, you found it.
We'll figure out why it went to spam.
Is there anybody thinking that you're gonna go out there
and build a brand and
and be posting stuff on your wall for 18 days?
Is there anybody up for that challenge?
As we have breakthroughs, as we're learning
to use the software, as you guys are seeing stuff on the
screen, as I'm giving you guys hooks,
as you're seeing me blow up my wall, is there anybody
that plans on going out there and doing this?
Type in the chat. Let me know.
Uh, James, I'm gonna send you a message myself.
Watch for it.
Try to log in there. James,
if you can't get access, I'll go look it up.
If there, if you guys are planning on doing this, I,
I got a special announcement for you.
You ready for this? As long as you're one
of our platinum members, I can't,
I can't do it on the $27 level guys,
but you wanna come in for this.
Okay, here's what I'm gonna do.
If you guys are willing to do that,
and by the way, you can use this group,
you can use people in this group to comment,
to beat the algorithm
and everything as long as you guys are willing to do that.
Why am I asking again? 'cause
we have brand new people on the call.
Thomas, as long as you guys are willing to do that,
we are gonna set it up to where you can go out there
and offer the installs for free
and we will handle all of it for you.
How does that sound? You're gonna be able to go out there
and you're gonna be able to use this hook to get people in.
Here's the reason why.
When you get them in
and you onboard 'em, they're gonna say, what do I do now?
And what is that gonna lead to for you guys?
What is it gonna lead to? Anybody?
Yeah, it's gonna lead to a conversation
where you're gonna be able to make a sale
for the most requested service in the world.
Does that make sense to you guys?
So we're already setting all this up for you so
that you're gonna be able to go and give 'em access, okay?
Now there's two things that we can do, right?
We can go and give them access to
what you guys are seeing right now, okay?
And, uh, it'll be more simplified than this.
Or if you're smart, what you'll do
is you'll go create your own little tutorial videos.
How many of you saw three minute tutorial videos,
uh, in that members area?
Yes or no? Who saw three minute tutorial videos?
You can create simple little videos like that
and put 'em on a Google Doc.
and put 'em inside a course sprout.
You can create your own goals, you can copy it.
I don't care. You're not a threat to me.
I want you to win, right? I don't care what you do.
So that when you're on your wall and you're showing things
and you're telling people common open claw,
common open claw, right?
And people are doing this,
we will give them access to Claw Launcher.
You'll give them access to Claw launcher.
Does that make sense to you guys? And from there they can go
through my tutorials or they can go through your tutorials.
What I would recommend guys, is I would take the day,
I would recreate those tutorials so that for the next
18 days, and then if you're part of platinum
and you wanna continue to 3.0
and remember when you're platinum, I'm going
to approve your affiliate link.
You guys are gonna have an affiliate link to invite people
to our webinars and launches and everything.
We're gonna prove that for you, okay?
Because there's a lot of hype around this. Alright?
But here's the thing. For the next 36 days,
why not do like I'm doing and blow up your wall?
This stuff is shiny, man. People are eating it up.
And when you go out there and say, Hey, I'm gonna do this,
install for you for free
and uh, it's gonna cost you $5 a month.
How many of you think you can get some people
commenting yes or no?
Who can get some people commenting?
I told you guys, man, for the next 18 days,
we're gonna be making money, we're gonna be making cheddar.
Yeah, yeah, we're gonna do it.
So we're gonna focus on, uh,
selling these services to clients.
We're gonna focus on building up your brand,
building up your reputation.
I don't care who you are, it don't matter.
'cause now we can ask chat PT
to make us look like a million bucks.
All those images on my wall, most of 'em come from chat.
GPT, all the images on the beautiful slides
that you saw, cha GPT.
So if you learn to make the right hook
and you tell everybody, I'll install it for you for free,
how is that not gonna work?
It's gonna work. And we'll,
we'll handle the heavy lifting for you.
We'll, we'll give 'em access to, uh,
our incredible software that g built.
Is everybody understanding this right now?
You guys starting to get this? It's good stuff, right?
It's good stuff. So we're gonna take care of you. All right?
So, uh, we're working on that.
Um, but let me see if I can find the hands over here.
So we got Terry Huckabee, Ernest Hill, uh, Marty.
Let me look up Marty, myself.
Marty, I'm gonna send you a message real quick to try
to help the team out for a minute.
Uh, hold on just a minute. Let me send you a, uh, message.
Uh, if I could figure out where the heck to do that.
Now I understand why people are having trouble.
Uh, okay, there it is. Uh, hey Marty.
Okay, do you see my message?
Marty, gimme your email address real quick.
If you would give me email
and let me see if I can look that up.
Um, by the way, uh, what I should be doing
is I should just be, uh, having open claw
researching all this stuff for us, right?
We don't, we don't even need to have, uh,
a bunch of hands just went up.
Uh, let me check in with g, G
and pne. Are you guys doing all right?
Yeah, Ted, I think I can share his screen
and then so some troubleshooting options.
So some of them can resolved.
Okay, perfect. And you know what?
I knew you were gonna say that. I was just waiting for you.
All right, go ahead G. Hey
everybody, listen to G for a minute.
He's gonna help you.
And Marty, I'm messaging you.
Okay? Uh, can you guys see my screen right now?
Can Yeah, we see it. We see it. Okay.
Okay. So, uh, if you have created your account
and then you're logged in like this
and uh, some of you can see an option like this,
like you don't have any part there
and sometimes you're trying to go to AI engine
and try to put your API key, right?
And you're saying no environment available
or something, it's because you haven't created the bot yet.
So if you have that green box in between, like saying, oh,
there's an option here saying create a new bot,
create a new cloud bot, please do that first
and then you'll be able to do all this.
You don't even have to come into this step.
This is a separate step. And okay, another one is, uh,
Wait, hold, hold on a sec, hold on a second.
'cause I wasn't looking. Can you show that again?
Yeah. So, uh, some of, uh, some
of them are doing something like this.
They're, instead of going to the chat
and then there's a big green button in the middle, instead
of clicking that, uh,
what you guys are doing is coming into AI engine
for some reason and entering your
API key here directly, right?
Mm-hmm. And then you get an error saying no environment,
but you haven't created your bot yet, right?
So the API key is for nothing.
So that's why you're getting that error.
So, uh, just go through the step and create the bot.
Okay? Hold on a second. So let me stop you there, right
guys, follow the videos please.
At no time did I ever click on usage AI engine or server.
You don't need to click any of those things.
The only thing you ever need to click on
after you're onboarding is the chat can,
can everybody understand that right now?
Can you guys type in the chat?
Let me know that you get that.
Follow the videos to a T, right?
All this other stuff is here for troubleshooting later,
but right now we're just trying to get you installed.
So you just click on chat and that's it.
Like, do not deviate from the videos
or, um, you, you gotta understand something.
This is installing some magical stuff on your CloudFlare
that nobody else is doing.
We're the first ones to do this, okay?
There's a lot of stuff happening behind the scenes
and if you don't do it in the exact order, then
that install is gonna fail.
Is that making sense to everybody?
If you look at what Mike's saying, he says,
follow the video, super helpful, watch some,
pause the video, do what it tells you, then push play again.
Repeat, yeah, just I try to keep the videos as short
and simple as possible.
There's a goal block there.
Just follow the videos
and you guys will not have this issue.
Okay? G go ahead. Yep.
Okay. Now, under the troubleshooting stuff, like this bot,
I intentionally broke.
So it's just going through, some
of you are seeing like 16 minutes here, like going
through the same thing, right?
If you're seeing that, uh, what I suggest to you is, uh,
if you're on this bot, just go to the server option
down here you'll see the option to delete the bot, try to go
and delete, and you have
to type in the name of the bot that you have.
So just type in that like that and just delete it
and you'll have a clean slate.
Uh, let me actually delete it.
Just delete that and you'll have a clean slate like this.
Uh, give it a minute.
Okay? Lemme rephrase. Yeah,
so you'll see something like this
and what you guys are doing is coming in here, right?
But you don't have a bot yet, so just create the bot.
You can, you can click in here or click in here.
You just create the bot going through this process
and that's how you do it.
And, uh, okay, another troubleshoot option is,
let's say you're having the problem over
and over, like you're seeing the same thing,
you did the entire thing
and you're still getting the problem.
What you can do is come into this profile down below.
Uh, if you're seeing this, click in this profile.
Uh, go to your profile option
and then you'll see the infrastructure option over here.
Click on that one. And once it's loaded, you'll see a,
you'll see a previewed configuration over here,
okay?
You'll see a configuration like this.
And what you can do is remove the configuration from here.
And once you do, you'll see the form again, the form
that you saw at the beginning.
You'll see the form again,
and you can input your data again.
That way it'll troubleshoot.
And why, and why would they do that again?
Uh, let's say the bot is not running,
like it's completely spinning over and over, right?
Yeah. If that's the case, then you can, uh,
just troubleshoot it from here.
Like, uh, delete the configuration
and re add your CloudFlare API tokens and everything.
Okay? It just takes you back to square one. Yeah.
And why would that, why would that be happening though?
Like, why would it loop like that?
Uh, right now I think we have a lot
of people signing in at the same time.
And then, uh, okay, so it's a,
It's a bandwidth. Yeah,
It's a bandwidth. It's a bandwidth
right now. Yeah.
So let me just help you guys understand this.
That's a one time thing, right?
Like once you're installed on your CloudFlare,
you're not like sharing instances with people
or anything like that, like you're on your own.
Does that make sense to everybody?
Like we just gotta get past trying
to get everybody installed all at once.
Does that make sense? I just wanna make sure everybody,
today's gonna be the most painful day out of all of this,
guys, I promise you, right?
Uh, it's just getting installed.
Once we get you past this point, you're good. Okay?
Uh, I'm, I'm over here trying to, uh, help people to, um,
okay, so Tom's good.
Uh, okay, G go ahead and continue.
Yeah, so if you delete the configuration like this,
you'll see this option again.
I think you saw this screen previously, right?
So all you're gonna do is enter all those values
again and then connect.
And once you're connected, you can come back to the chat
and create a new bot again.
And also, so lemme ask you, lemme ask you a question.
'cause I'm talking to, uh, Doug Starks right now,
and he says, I'm getting this air message when trying
to set up my claw launcher invalid CF or token
or account idea, could not route
to blah, blah, blah, blah. Should he do that?
So that means, so that means, uh, he's having trouble
with, uh, his account ID or API token
or any other of of these values.
So when he copied the values, it's probably wrong.
So you wanna take what you copied,
Okay? So now what though?
Does he need
to do the whole infrastructure restart or,
Uh, if he completely lost it, like, uh,
the values are completely lost, he has to go back
and, uh, recreate the tokens
because CloudFlare is not gonna give you, again, you,
you can only copy once, right?
So if you're doing, if you're going through that process,
I suggest you open up a notepad
or something, paste your values over
there and then continue.
Okay? And also if you have all the values correct, make sure
what you're copying, right?
So sometimes you copy, you try to copy,
but the clipboard doesn't have the same value
and you, you pay something random like this, right?
For example. And it would say, okay, for example,
if I do this, I have typed something random, right?
I'm gonna get the same error. So, uh, CCF token
or account is account ID route.
I think you are getting exact same error, right?
If you're saying this, then yeah, it's definitely
because the values are wrong.
Okay. Doug, can you,
can you double check your values again
and just make sure there's no extra
spaces or anything there?
Yeah, You said I've tried about eight times,
been copying and pasting
for my notepads, so it should be working.
So that means the value that you copied
to Notepad could be wrong.
So you gotta recreate the id.
Can you, because there's nothing can,
Yeah, can you re um, can you just go back in
where you got the account ID or whatever
and just copy that again.
Like I, I don't know. I mean it's, yeah, I don't know.
Yeah, this part, uh, we can't really do anything.
It's up to you what you copy.
So yeah, that would be the part.
And another one, uh,
let's say you are creating the bot, right?
Uh, I see some people getting confused,
like you copied like uh, how many values here you copied uh,
four of the values, right?
And then you see, okay, I have all the values.
And then you go to the chat
or you create a new bot, you go to this step,
you select a plan, you give it a name,
and then you come into this step
and you're confused like, what do I put in here?
Right? I've seen the, seen some of the messes
with this, with this problem.
This is gonna be your anthropic API key, the cloud API key.
If you haven't created that,
I think Chad has a video on how you can do that.
So please uh, check that one.
Let's see. Ricardo says, the first time I copied the
CloudFlare IDs four slash APIs, it gave me an error
but I waited a little bit and it disappeared on its own.
Um, wait, did you see that message?
I'm just looking at what Ricardo said.
He said the first time I copied the CloudFlare IDs APIs,
it gave me an error, but I waited a little bit
and it disappeared on its own.
Okay. And were you able
to create a new ID if you were able to create a new id?
You can use that.
The answer is yes. Carla, you are platinum at 9 97.
I'm stuck there. It looks like mine is set up,
but it does not respond when asking questions.
How about that one G?
Uh, can you say that again? Said,
Uh, it looks like mine is set up,
but it does not respond when asking questions.
Okay, so that's the another troubleshooting problem.
So, um, let's say you have connected the bot,
you see the body screen, you can chat to it,
but it doesn't respond to you, right?
So in that case, uh,
first question is are you using entropic API key?
Are you using cloud API key like entropic
and then cloud sonet or something?
Anything you have here? If not,
then any other model could be having problem right now.
We are gonna fix that. We are gonna bring in, uh,
the Kimi as well here.
But right now we just have entropic. Please try to use that.
And even though you have the cloud
and you're still having problem, you're in this chat
and you're having problem, what you can do is come
to this AI engine.
If you have the bot, uh, come to this AI engine,
put your an API key again here, the correct one,
and then just hit save settings.
Let's should reset the bot with the new key
and then you should try to talk to it again.
So can you, um, who was saying that?
Was it Ryan who was saying, um, Terry,
it looks like mine is set up but does not respond.
Can you do what he just showed you in this video?
By the way, guys, all these little troubleshooting things
that G is showing right now,
I will create simple little short videos to show you
how to get around all this.
Okay? It is just, right now I'm learning this myself.
We've been so focused on the onboarding
and everything that now we're going into troubleshooting.
And what's amazing about the troubleshooting
that G is building in is we no longer have
to do like open claw, gateway, restart, doctor fix.
We don't have to do none of that stuff
'cause he's got it all cooked in
where you're just gonna be able to come in here
and add different API keys it.
You don't have to do any of that stuff, right?
It's gonna be so much better. So there you go.
Steve Pond is in, just had my first conversation.
Uh, can he do it again? Mine was set at Anthropic.
I kept asking what I choose. Yeah.
So if you look on the left side, uh, Terry,
click on AI engine.
Okay? Uh, Terry, if you're having the same problem again,
um, did you get your API key?
If you got your A PPI key,
then you can just select tropic here by default.
And then over here you can select cloud.
So eight, 4.5, let's do that.
If you guys are in, can you type in the chat?
Let me know that you're in. Let me know
that you have claw launcher installed.
Elaine is in. Watch the video.
If you're stuck, you gotta watch a video.
I'm in Claw launcher. Yes, I'm in still working on it.
Martin says I'm in, I have it installed,
but it's not talking back to me.
Norman, do what he just showed you.
And also guys, if you're seeing this problem,
it says command failed or something like that.
Uh, give it a try in a while.
I think we have a lot of people connecting at once
and then it's trying to run the command at
once for all of them.
Like the survey is super loaded right now,
so you can try it again.
I think nothing's wrong with your key
because it's not giving you any error like that.
So please try again with the key in a while.
What about the funding part G?
Do they have to spend the $40 to get anthropic to talk?
Not really. You can just have $5.
You guys gotta make sure that you have anthropic funded.
Yeah, but you have to have fund though at, yeah.
Yeah, at least five. At least five.
So, um, here's the thing, man.
This doesn't make us any, any special this, this just,
we're just the ones that are willing to show up
and bite the bullet and try to try to get everybody
to the finish line, right?
And so if you look online, all everybody is trying to
do all this from command prompts and VPSs
and it's super, super complicated.
So what we're going through right now is expected, guys,
there's gonna be challenges with this.
It is rather technical, right?
But we are, um, very, very determined, uh,
and dedicated to you to sit here and answer these questions
and, and try to help you the best we can so
that you don't gotta be out there on Facebook
saying, I can't get this to work.
Is, does that make sense?
So you guys gotta kind of have a little bit of patience
with us 'cause it's definitely a challenge
to get everybody there, right?
Uh, can you show us quick here how to fund the claw launch?
You don't, you don't fund claw launcher,
you just use claw launcher to, uh, launch your,
uh, your open claw.
That's all. There's no funding there. Okay?
Um, if Telegram connected on old VPS,
can I use the same token?
I had that question last night
too, G when I was shooting the video.
Can we use the same token or no?
Uh, which token are you talking about?
If, if they're coming from 1.0
and already have the CloudFlare token,
Uh, CloudFlare token or cloud token?
Um, I'm, I'm sorry. The, um, uh, telegram token.
Oh, telegram Token. Yeah, you can still use that,
but uh, what happens is the other bot you had set up
that will stop working only this will work.
So, uh, the Telegram bot can only be
connected to one thing, right?
So it'll be disconnected from the other one
and it'll connect this one.
All right. Looks like Jordan's fixed. Uh, me too.
He said he needed to do that. Get to level two.
Not sure what that allows us to do.
I don't understand it either.
I think it's clause's way of making a lot of money.
But if, if you're not on level two, uh,
it'll send you these limit, uh, errors all the time, right?
So when you get to level two, you don't get those messages,
you don't hit those token limits.
Claude was pretty smart when they came up with tier two,
tier three, tier four.
It was really a smart move.
Um, okay, so Terry, Terry, Huckabee, Dave Fazz, Craig,
Anthony, Norman, and Dean.
You guys all have your hands up.
Do you mean for your hands to be up?
And let me check in with Pne
and Hannah, where are we at on these people?
With their hands?
There's a, yeah, they're trying to
Get to them, but, and waiting for their response.
Okay. So who are you waiting on response from?
Norman. Who? Norman. Okay.
Norman, can you check your message?
Brene has sent you a message. Uh, who else?
Dean. Dean, can you check your message? Who else?
Uh, that's all I have. Okay.
Um, Let me see.
Uh, Craig, Anthony, you said the questions in the chat.
My question in chat, what, what's the question? Craig?
Can we use the same Claude API we used in 1.0?
The answer is yes. The answer is yes.
Go ahead and put your hand down. The, the people
that have their hands up,
you should have your hands up if you don't have
access to the members area.
I still wanna make sure we got
everybody access to the training.
'cause if people don't have access to the training,
they're not gonna be able to get this done, right?
So put your hand down if you don't
need access to the training.
And what I wanna do is let's just go ahead
and make note of the names Hannah, that the people
that don't have access to the training,
and then I'm gonna have people raise
their hand for the real issues.
Okay? So Dean FIAs, Dave
and Terry, I'm assuming you guys don't have access
to the training area, correct?
Uh, okay, let me grab a screenshot of that.
Okay, I got a screenshot. Okay.
These people right here, uh, Hannah, I'm gonna send to you.
Supposedly they're the ones that need access
to the training, okay?
Need training. Okay, here we go.
Now, now I want everybody to go ahead
and we're gonna put our hands down, okay?
So we know who, um, uh, we're gonna reach out
to Terry Huckabee, Dave FIAs, and Dean.
Okay. Still watch for your messages. Okay?
Now everybody's hands are down.
Now what I need you to do is put your hand up
if you are having trouble with, um, claw launcher.
Okay? If you're having trouble with API keys, stuff like
that, go ahead and put your hand up.
Okay? And I'm gonna send this image to you, uh,
Hannah, real quick.
Save. Alright, now,
um, g with these hands that are up,
do we wanna start sharing some screens
or what should we do to make this easy?
Yeah, I think sharing a screen would be a lot easier.
Okay. Hold on just a minute, guys.
Let me send this to Hannah
and then we'll start looking at some of the screen shares,
and we will do our best to get everybody there today, okay?
And I'm, I'm sure
that people are gonna have the same issues occurring over
and over and over and over
and over, which is gonna be a good thing.
Okay? So let me go ahead
and do, uh, this here.
Okay? Five, delete five.
All right, hold on a second. And hopefully, uh,
nobody's irritated with the process today, guys.
This is just, if you rely on people
to answer back support tickets, stuff like that,
I have found the only way to get everybody
to the finish line is to do what we're doing right now
and just fix it on the spot.
Right? Okay. So, um, Sam, Courtney, what's the issue, buddy?
Okay. I am in claw launcher for, I,
I removed it as G went over, started from scratch,
put in my keys, uh, the CloudFare flare,
uh, IDs and everything. And it's,
Do you wanna share your screen?
Um, yeah, let me,
I'm a very visual
person. I need you to share your screen.
Sure, sure.
I share the right screen. You seeing,
you seeing launch? Yes, sir.
Yes, Sir. Okay. I've been stuck here for
the timer's going up, not down.
It's at six minutes. It keeps going up.
It was up to like 13 the last time
I removed everything started over
and it's doing the same thing again.
Okay, G. Okay, Sam, uh,
did you delete the CloudFlare configuration as well?
Like, did you delete the bot
and then then configuration, like SOD?
Yes. Okay. And you're still reading the
I can do it again though.
Yeah. Uh, you want to delete the go to the server first?
Delete what? Uh,
you see the server option on the left side down below
This part? Yeah, right
here. The profile,
You mean? No, no,
on the left side, just above that, your name, uh,
you see that server option?
Keep going up down below? Yeah.
Yeah, server. Yeah.
Yeah, it scroll all the way to the bottom.
Now delete the bot. Did you do this one?
Yeah, I did. Okay,
Do it again now And then.
Uh, okay. Now delete, go to the profile
and delete the setting as well.
All right.
So it's basically starting over this point.
Is it starting over from this point G? Okay.
Yeah. What it does is on their CloudFlare account,
everything, every configuration is reset.
So,
So now, yeah, now everything just needs
to be entered back in, put CloudFare info in,
and then can you see what I'm doing?
Or should I stop sharing? Yeahm sharing the screen.
Not is everybody,
Yeah, so if you wanna hide, you can just stop saving
My key if I'm like, yeah.
So stop saving and then you can put in
your keys and then come back.
Okay. One sec.
Hey, you gotta have the notepad.
I've got like 15 APIs on a notepad.
Without that I'd be lost.
You gotta do that first, like you said, for sure.
Uh, Chad, you're muted.
All right, we'll check back in with you here in a minute.
Sam, Valerie, what you got going on?
I think I may be okay.
I was trying to recreate my claw bot
and then I got an error,
but the error has gone away, so I think I'm okay.
Yeah. So I think you saw that error on the chat, right?
Saying pairing error or something? Is that what you saw?
Um, it had a, it had a disconnection error,
but that went away.
Oh yeah, it goes away after a while.
So on the initial setup, it shows the error
and then it says pairing issue
and then everything happens automatically.
That's the way it's set up.
Okay. So you're good, Valerie?
I think so. I've got a chat box open, so
that makes me think it may be ready.
Is it it talking to you? Um, are you
Scared? Are you scared to
talk to?
I called it test. Lemme see if it answers.
Um, the assistant just put a timestamp on it,
so I guess it's answering
Well. It'll answer you.
Okay, so I don't, it didn't say any words,
so I don't know if it's configured correctly.
Can you share your screen so we can look at it?
Yeah. Um, hold on. Share.
You have funded your Claude API key, right?
I don't know. Um, If you don't, it won't talk to you.
Okay. I have two screens,
so I dunno if you're gonna see the right thing.
Do you see it? I don't see it. Um,
It's coming in.
Yeah, we see a bright, bright green screen.
Yeah. And that's the wrong screen.
Okay, well you woke me up, sorry.
Oh, how do I undo that? Uh, let's see.
Carvin is all set. Let me know when you guys are all set.
I'm telling you man, we're gonna get you guys there.
Let me know when you're all set. Let
me know when you got it installed.
Uh, yeah, I'll show you how to fund it here in a minute.
Uh, Bronson no problem.
I'm gonna pull this over.
Okay, now share.
Okay. Yeah. Uh, it is definitely not talking to you.
Um, okay, so if you were to go to platform.claude.com,
uh, there's an API key there
and there's a menu item that says billing.
You need to add a credit card.
And what I would do if I was you, is I'd make sure
that there's at least $5 there for this thing to talk back.
Okay? Try to do that first.
If that doesn't work, then we'll do some
of the troubleshooting that G showed us
with changing out the API key and stuff like that.
Can you try that first?
Yeah, that might take me a minute.
So I'll stop sharing so you can work with someone else.
Yeah, that's okay. But keep your hand
up till we get you fixed, okay?
Okay. All right. How are we looking? Sam?
Sam, Courtney, how are we looking?
Can you hear me?
I couldn't unmute until you hit the button. Oh, okay.
Um, I went into the infrastructure, I put in all my info,
and then I noticed it said CloudFare account pending.
I had a little yellow window, so I refreshed it,
and now I've got a circle spin
and nothing's come back up yet,
but I don't know if that was my issue.
There's something wrong with CloudFare
or if it just took a few minutes to,
you know, get in the system.
So I don't see any errors there.
And cloud fare's end
and I clicked all my verification emails and whatnot.
So be Do you wanna share,
Do you wanna share a screen so we can see
It? Yep. Yep.
Yes, Mike, you are done, my friend.
That was the whole goal for today.
Uh, that's what we're gonna do today, guys.
We are going to get this thing
where it's talking to everybody.
Um, so if you guys are done, uh, let me, let me get you guys
to do one thing for me real quick.
If we can. Uh,
and these are the people that we're going
to approve their affiliate link.
I'd like to be able to, uh, keep track of that.
If you were on the intensive today, how many
of you now have a talking version
of Open Claw?
How moving forward?
All right, I'm gonna make this simple little post
before you guys leave.
If you'll just answer this, this'll be on my wall.
Uh, everybody that answers it, these are the people
that we are going to, uh, approve
with their affiliate link and everything else.
So let me put this in the chat.
Somebody was asking about that. Hey, Chad.
So Hold on just a minute here.
I'm can you just a minute, Sam. Okay.
So, uh, let me make sure that that open real quick. Hold on.
Share copy link. Okay.
Uh, are you guys seeing this here?
Is everybody seeing that link?
Let me know if you're seeing that link.
I put it in the chat. Does everybody see that?
Make sure you comment. Let us know that yes,
you have it working, it is installed.
Tell us how excited you are.
Tell us what you expect to achieve from this workshop.
Just tell 'em how great the, the process was,
the videos, like that whole thing.
'cause the whole marketplace is watching me right now,
and they're, a lot of 'em are hoping that I fall on my butt
and fail with this thing,
but I don't, I don't care if I gotta be here all day.
We will get every last person, uh,
to the finish line on this call.
So, uh, yes, please, please, please comment on there.
Uh, that would be great.
And, uh, let me head back over here to Sam. All right.
Sam, do you wanna share your screen?
Yeah, sorry, I was just putting in my key.
Um, it did finally say CloudFare was
active and now I am
here, uh, waiting for this to continue.
And once I get past this spot is where it gets hung up.
Hopefully, maybe this time it won't. Um, okay.
And you know for a fact, you don't have to show it,
but you know, for a fact that's the right API key.
Uh, yeah. And you know, it's funded,
Uh, yeah. Okay.
Funded it yesterday, uh, even went back
and double checked to make sure it was right
when I was first having the, uh, problems.
So yeah, everything should be right on my end.
Now we're wanna do that. Okay.
So here we are. This is where it gets hung up.
It will start going, the green goes to the end
and it's moving faster now.
So,
Yeah. So we
are definitely having this bandwidth problem
where everyone's trying to create their container, right?
Uh, what we are doing is from our side, we try
to create a container on your CloudFlare account.
And, uh, what's happening is everyone's trying
to create the container on their CloudFlare, right?
And we are trying to initiate everything.
So maybe that's causing some problem
with some of the accounts.
Like some of the people are already live,
but for some of them it's happening problem.
Like, uh, you see on the CloudFlare,
it's trying to create the container.
Some of it is happening, some of it is not. Right?
So if you, if you keep having this issue
and then, uh, you know how to troubleshoot this process,
you can try it later and it, it'll probably work.
But right now, since everyone's doing the same thing at the
same time, that's probably, uh, causing the issue.
It's a bandwidth issue. Yeah.
The one time bandwidth issue
because now people will just settle all this up from
the members area, right?
It was kind of a big scary blast today. Yeah.
And Uh, which actually I'm pretty,
I'm pretty happy the way it went, honestly. Yeah.
It's when we weren't even ready to like,
do the mass like this, right?
We're signing up all the accounts,
we didn't even create the accounts from ourself.
Mm-hmm. And then, yeah, I think a lot
of people got active, so that's good.
And, uh, the ones that you're having problem,
you can try again if you know
what the process to troubleshoot now.
Nice. Okay.
So I'm gonna check back in with you here,
uh, in a minute. Okay,
Sam, it goes, it gets to about and it's, sure,
Yeah, we're gonna check back in with you,
but we will, we will check back in.
Alright? Uh,
Okay. Thanks.
No problem. Uh, Dave, you're up. What's up buddy?
Dave, can you
talk Dave?
Okay, we'll come back to Dave. Uh, Richard Hall.
Can you talk there?
Richard Hall? Where you, you at buddy? How you doing?
Okay. Appreciate all your patience today. Sure.
Um, I'll share my screen easily
because I'm, uh, connected with you
through my mobile, through my phone.
'cause I've been moving around, but I have, uh,
logged in on my laptop so I'm not, uh, able to
share it, I guess at this moment.
But my problem is that I, I got into claw launcher,
but it's totally frozen, apparently.
Uh, it's not responding when I hit chat or reset
or restart or my login.
Uh, I mean, my profile.
Are you trying to do this from your phone?
No. Okay. No, I'm logged in
on my phone just for the communication?
Yeah. 'cause I was moving around
before I got back to the office and now I'm on the laptop,
but I, the laptop, I just am logged in
as a user. Got to call
Or, okay, lemme check with, lemme check with G.
I got your problem. Uh, g
what do we do when it's not responding?
Uh, I think the entire software is, uh,
like not responding on his side.
It's definitely like, uh, a lot
of user using it at the same time.
It's just a result. It, uh, resolve itself.
It's give it a minute and, uh, we, we can try again.
But he's, he's already installed it or no?
No, he's saying that he
couldn't even navigate to anything.
Once we get past the install process, guys,
which clearly is a bandwidth issue, you'll be set free.
You're on your own container,
your own bandwidth, no conflict.
It's just, right now our software's trying
to install everybody on CloudFlare
and that sounds like what the conflict is.
So your advice to him is check it in a few minutes.
Yeah. Okay.
I can log out and log in, uh,
and, uh, try it in a, in like sometime.
Okay. I'm gonna check back
in with you here in a little bit, Richard. Okay?
Definitely. Okay, thanks.
Alright buddy. Uh, Doug Starks, where you at? Chief?
Hey Chad, I'm trying to still, uh, set up Claw launcher.
Okay. Can you share your screen?
Yeah. Lemme see here.
I was over here talking to you, but I need G'S help,
So Yeah, I'm, We're seeing your API
keys. You might not wanna show that.
Yeah. Sorry. Oh, no, you don't,
don't have, don't have to be sorry to me.
Yeah, but just make sure, I
Just make sure once you get this talking
that you change API keys after the call. Okay.
Yeah. Trust me. We've had to do that many times
By the way. You have an
extra step at space at the end.
You copied this space.
Yeah, I've, the first part
of the setup I've done several times
and I'm here, so I'm hoping this works.
Well, he's saying that you just copied it
and you copied an extra space.
Oh, did I? I don't know how the heck share
My screen. You saw that, that
quick, but he saw it.
Yeah. Let me see.
Lemme stop share for a second.
And everybody else, I put the link in the chat,
if you'll just let us know that you got your open claw live
and kick in and you got it installed.
Um, if you can just please leave that comment for us.
We'd really appreciate your support in the community.
Uh, and other than that,
I'll see you guys tomorrow on the call.
You don't have to stick around unless you want to.
And like I said, my goal today is
to take all the troubleshooting that we're going through.
I'll shoot simple little videos for people
to get past some of these issues.
Uh, and we'll have those in the members area too, so that,
um, we're, we're kind of using this to see
all the possible scenarios.
Then we'll document 'em and then we'll create videos
to help people get past it.
Okay. All right, Doug, go ahead and, um, share that.
Yeah, I think I put it in now correctly, so
we'll see.
How long did it go last time?
I never got to this part until now,
so I'm farther than I have.
I kept having to put those three, you know, the keys
and everything and about eight times.
Okay. You know what? So, Uh, yeah,
We're gonna check back into here, Doug. Okay.
All right. Appreciate it.
No problem. Thanks for help. All right.
You're welcome. Uh,
Ricardo, what do you got going on, chief? How you doing?
Uh, thanks. Fine, thanks.
My, uh, let me share my, my, uh, account is, uh,
let me share, uh, is, uh, where was the,
the, the Doug one?
So, uh, let me share, where is the
hold on screens?
Uh, this one. So
I'm here
and, uh, I had, uh, uh, quite, uh, some errors, but
before, but, uh, they dissolved
and I already had, uh, the chat working.
But, uh, when I changed the,
because I, I connected Gemini when I changed to
Claude, then, uh, I always have this almost already,
so I already done twice,
But, okay. And, uh,
when you had Zoom, it was, was it talking to you?
Was it, uh, responding to you back?
Uh, I didn't have no errors,
but I didn't, uh, checked if, uh, it was, uh, responding.
Okay. Uh, can you go to the AI engine again?
And, uh, uh, you don't wanna sew your key,
but, uh, try to enter your, will
You be able to, to get Katie?
So to, uh, uh, put the, the key again?
Yeah, it's fine. It'll, it'll hide if you paste in there.
We don't, we didn't see the key,
but don't sew the notepad or anything.
Yeah. So, uh, it's correct. Right.
And you see that clause Sonet 4.5.
Can you change it to 3.50, it's, it's 4.5.
Yeah, that's fine. Okay. It's saved.
Okay. Let's give it a minute
until it says configuration has saved.
Okay.
But I think it's, uh, the, it's, uh, something, uh, related
to the bandwidth because, uh, it's, uh, very, very slow
Now. Yeah. The entire
site is super slow right now.
Yeah.
Yeah. Give it a minute. I think we can, uh, bounce back
to you and then, uh, give it a minute.
Let it save. Yeah. Don't rephrase or anything.
And then it should restart your bot and then it should work.
Okay. Okay. Ricardo, I'm gonna check back in with you.
Okay.
Um, uh, let's see.
FIAs, are you there?
Yeah, I'm here. How you doing? You okay?
Good. How are you doing? I'm fine.
I think I'm getting there, but, um, probably,
probably it's gone missing, right?
I've been trying to ask you for, for a few questions.
Um, right. Okay. So, uh, I've got up two, um, here.
Um, if I share my screen, um, okay, so
I sent you a message G.
Okay. Uh, this is the same problem, um,
that I just explained.
Um, so what you're doing is you're trying
to enter the key without creating the bot.
So on the left side where you see
that create your first clock on the top, very top, yeah.
Yeah. So you gotta click that button,
and now you gotta create a bot.
And then you put the API key.
So you can, you can simply select the light version Yeah.
And continue with light. Now give it a name.
Anything can, anything is fine. It's up to you.
Okay. Oh, so you, you haven't even, uh,
added your CloudFlare, uh, IDs
No.
Off. So you're gonna do this first.
Can I hold you guys off for a minute?
Can you close that window for me just for a minute? FIAs?
Yeah. Look, go ahead and share your screen again.
I want you guys to see something.
This is very, very important.
If you look in the, go ahead
and close that little popup real for a minute.
The what? The one that says connect CloudFlare.
Close that look in the top left corner of his screen.
See how it says connect your first claw.
If it says that you guys should not be dealing with API keys
or anything, the first thing you gotta do is you gotta
connect your claw.
And as you go through that process, it'll ask you
to enter your API key.
Yeah. So simply click on the chat.
On the chat. You See the, do you see
the chat on the left side?
Yeah. Yeah. This is where you're supposed to be.
So you see that you, you don't have any bot, right?
But you're trying to change the settings for the bot.
The bot doesn't even exist.
Yeah. I've been following your training one by one
by one video, and the PR has been there as well.
So on the actual, uh, videos, um, oops. Oh, got it.
Set up all these again now. Okay, fine.
I'll have to redo it again. Right.
But, uh, on your, uh, videos, uh, which I was watching, um,
and I was going through the training,
I'm going in this order, I'm going
exactly as Parnes telling me.
So, um, where I've got to here, uh,
he's told me to get everything done.
I've done exactly what you, you've got written here,
and I was kind of up to here.
So I was following the instructions exactly here.
Nowhere here does it say open up, uh,
and to go through this instruction, what we,
what you're just telling me now.
Uh, it doesn't say that here.
It doesn't follow through that here.
So what do I miss? Right?
I think it, I think it does
because people have got to the finish line, right?
Yeah. So let me make the difference. Hold on a second.
Let me see what I'm seeing versus what you're seeing. Okay.
So if, if we've come from the very, very start, okay,
so we open this up.
So hold of those, you're, you're gonna, hold on,
I'm gonna mute you if you don't stop, listen to me.
You gonna create your CloudFlare account, your token,
your account id, your R two tokens.
This is where you set up your $5.
And then here's where you set up your claw launcher.
Did you go through this one? Because everything is,
everything is here, right?
Uh, your actual, uh, open claw from your,
and so everything, everything is in order.
And this is the reason why we've had
so many people be successful today.
All right? So you can see it is deploying.
We are almost done. It is
now, can you pause the video for a minute?
Deploying the worker. So here's the thing.
If you go through, if you go through the video step by step,
and I, I don't wanna mislead people
and say that it's not right when it is, right?
We have people getting to the finish line,
but you gotta make sure that, um, you do every single step
that's there, right?
It's there, it's all there. It's in order.
You'll, you'll go to the first part and,
and you'll launch your, um,
what the heck's it called your claw launcher.
And then the second part is
where you'll gather the
credentials for the onboarding process.
Fine, fine. Okay. Uh, so just a bit of misunderstanding
with the then, 'cause I was asking
about, do I need to set up my voice?
Do I need to do this? So I was on another part
of the training, uh,
without actually having finished the first part.
So I didn't do the last bit, so my bad.
And, um, so no, it's not
A bad, it's not a bad, I just don't wanna tell people
that things are wrong when I know they're right.
But the second part, you won't need
to do the second part till it's actually
talking to you in the install. Does that make sense?
Yeah. Got you. No problems. That's okay. Fantastic.
That's okay. I'll get it redone. Don't worry.
Okay, so now I'm, um, I'm lost
where we're at in the process.
Oh yeah. So you gotta you gotta create your,
your claw launcher first.
Yep. Okay. All right.
So you let me know how that goes. Yeah,
Yeah, sure.
Okay, perfect. Yes. Thank you. Uh, Manny. What's up buddy?
Hey. Hi. Can you hear me? Mm-hmm.
I can hear you. How are you doing?
Good. So I did set up my claw launcher, you know,
with the API and all.
Mm-hmm. But crazy enough, the easiest thing is to, um, is
to grab the CLO API, I can't seem to find it.
And now watch your video. It looks like they might have
changed it slightly.
So I'm in the building, I paid a year in advance Uhhuh,
and I can't seem to find how to generate an API key in clo.
Oh, okay. So you're
Probably in the main account, right? Yeah.
You probably paid for something else.
You're definitely on the wrong place.
So maybe you can save your screen
and we can guide you where you can go.
Crap. All right, hold on.
Um, I have a 40 inch monitor, so forgive me.
Let me figure this out. Uh, 49, I think that's the one.
Share. Uh, can you see my screen? I don't know.
If's It's covering my entire screen.
Oh, yeah, we can see the screen.
So it's not this one here, Claude. Mm-hmm.
Um, you are in CLA now? Yeah. Okay. Alright.
And you can see us all done.
I'm gonna put this out here, right?
Uh, what we're doing is we're getting you onboarded as fast
as we possibly can, but the onboarding process
that we're going through right now, uh,
is not gonna be typical, right?
It's gonna be more secure,
but we're just trying to get everybody
onboarded as fast as we can.
And then we're gonna change the
process and reshoot these videos.
That's way it's gonna go. Alright?
So, uh, what we're gonna do is we're gonna have you set up,
uh, you're actually gonna sign up for
a claw launcher account right now.
Now that means anybody can do this,
but if they don't have all the credentials,
Um, so you're trying to get the API key
for Claude right now, right,
Manny?
Yes. Correct.
So, uh, the website you're on is for the Claude Pro.
You're, uh, you're trying to get the Claude Pro.
That's the wrong place. So, uh, if you can see the
Zoom chat, I've sent you a link. Can you open that up?
Let me, um, go to the Zoom.
Forgive me, I'm not used to this huge screen with Zoom yet.
Yeah. And I just checked the video too, Manny, the video
that's there takes you to the API key.
Oh my God. I Googled it. I should have, um, I couldn't.
Yeah, these, these platforms guys, I want you to know,
like you can pay for their, uh, AI service.
Then you can go get an API key, which is separate,
and you're gonna pay for usage on the API key, which most
of the time that's what's gonna happen with open claw.
You're just gonna get an API key
and then pay for the usage on the API key. Okay? Yeah.
So I'm gonna log in, continue with Google,
hopefully that's okay. And
Yeah, it should, it can be the same account
that you logged in with the other cloud, right?
This is the same platform, just, uh, this is for APIs.
Okay? So I'm not sure if you can
still see my screen, so forgive me.
Yeah, I'm seeing a screen. All right. Individual.
Yeah, you can see individual.
Mm-hmm. And,
And yeah, this is where you would see on the left side.
Do you see that? Or even in the middle of the screen,
do you see that gate API key option?
There are three boxes in the middle, right?
In the, oh, in the middle Uhhuh. Yeah.
And then on the very right side, you see that gate API key?
Yeah. Yeah. So don't source this
because it'll sew the API key on the call.
Everyone can see that. So you might wanna stop sharing,
but you, you, you gotta buy the, uh,
$5 credit at the beginning.
Okay? So this is what you're gonna buy.
Okay? So maybe I should come back.
Um, so you can help someone.
And then, uh, uh, yeah, while I'm there, um,
just wanna make sure, I think I set up, let me just show you
my other thing and then I'll let somebody
else, um, get a chance.
Uh, lemme see if I can, um, so sorry about that.
The benefit of having a big screen is nice,
but if you can't find it, it's almost useless.
I got way too many things. Um, oh, um, trying to see.
Oh, there it is. It's right beside.
So, um, can you tell if this is,
if I set up the API correctly
and all I need to do is create a new 'cause?
I think that's what Chad just said.
I can, uh, just, um, you know, at that point, name it,
and then I'm ready to go and add the API key right
after that for Claude. Mm-hmm.
Yeah. Did you already connect your CloudFlare?
Um, yes, I did. So I'm okay.
'cause otherwise it would've asked for the key. It like,
Yeah. Yeah. So if you
have already connected, then
that's the only step you have.
You're remaining. You just need the key.
Go through the process of creating the bot.
Just give it the API key and you should be fine.
All righty. Okay. I'll come back.
If I need help, I'll leave my hand up for a minute while I,
um, stop sharing.
Thank you so much, guys. Great job.
You're welcome. All right. Good job, G.
Um, Terry, you're up buddy. What's going on?
Terry Huckabee in the sharp looking suit.
Can you hear me? Okay? We'll come back to him.
Uh, I think it's al Did I say that right?
I'm sorry if I didn't say it right, but I think it's al
You said it perfectly. Thank you. Oh,
Look at there.
Better Enjoy it while you can.
It doesn't always happen that way.
Yeah. Alright, What you got going on?
Um, I can't get past cloud flare. Okay.
Share your screen. It it dumps me.
Yeah, I can show my screen.
Yeah. Oh, where is it?
Oh, wait, I don't know where it is now.
It's a button that says share.
Yeah, but it, what popped up, it was a lot of
this is what popped up. Can you see?
Mm-hmm. Once you click,
so you found the button that says share?
Yes. Yeah. And you need to choose the screen.
There you go. You got it. Yep. We see it.
We're looking at Claude right now.
Is that what we should be looking at?
No, that is not what you should be looking at. That's
Okay. Well, you can open up
CloudFlare if you want. I'm,
I'm lost.
I had it open for you.
I don't, this is very confusing.
Well just go ahead and type in CloudFlare.
What, what
was happening is that when I went to CloudFlare,
uh, and I made my email
and password, it just dumped me on a page
that says Developer's platform.
And there's another place where I can click on,
it's asking me for a domain name.
I even found where I could make, uh, input
or credit card, but it didn't give me any options
of different pay levels.
It's as if they know who I'm already,
I have an account home.
It says Crafty lady, my email,
and then it, it says Build with workers.
Yeah. I, I don't, I don't know.
Without seeing your screen. So why don't you find the
screen, come back and share with us.
'cause we're not getting anywhere with this. Oh, okay. Okay.
Yep. Find your screen and then we can help you. Okay.
Alright. Okay. Perfect.
Uh, David Scarborough, you're up.
It's not letting me, uh,
Create, can you share your screen?
Yeah. It's not letting me create a bot
and I don't know if I've got a bad API key.
Can we share the same clause API key
as we did in two or 1.0,
Yes.
Yeah. So then that's not the problem,
but, uh, yeah. Let me, can you
Share your screen please?
Yeah, I am, I'm not seeing that.
Uh, all right, let me do it again. Oh, here.
Um, right here.
There you go. Okay. We see.
All right. Yeah. So I, I create the bot uhhuh and I
Just click the started. Uh,
you gonna click the big green button
in the be in the middle?
Hit the, the hit this? Yeah, yeah,
Yeah.
Did you click it? That's not what, yeah. Yeah.
What the hell did I just do?
Uh, well, I think Zoom windows out there, right? Right.
Like when you said bunch of stuff from Zoom came up.
Yeah. I need to get this damn thing out of the way.
Yeah, that's what I needed to do.
He talks like me. Oh
Gee. Alright. So yeah,
so create the bot, get started,
select the light plan, and then continue.
And then I put it, I just put my name in.
Yeah, anything you want.
Yeah. And then I'll just put David,
and then I'll continue, and I go
and get my API key.
Hold on a second. And
there's my API key.
And then watch what'll happen.
It'll start to create,
and then it'll, um,
I'll get a red something and it'll say it didn't create it,
and then it, then it goes like it's going to do everything.
So then I load all of CloudFare stuff in there,
and then it doesn't work.
It keeps telling me it can't connect CloudFare.
And so then I come back and it says, oh. Oh, okay.
Yeah. So I see the problem.
It's, it's the problem with connection
with your CloudFlare account.
So, uh, let's see what happens. Let's give it a minute. But
Yeah, but it's not, it, it's not creating a bod.
Yeah. So I think I know the issue.
Let's wait a minute and then see what it actually says,
and then I can help you.
And it's never been this long.
It's, uh, usually it, it just goes, you know,
very quickly, it's
That bandwidth.
Is there anything that we can do with
It? Yeah. See? Okay,
so it, it got here. Oh,
Okay. So what
happened, um, is, uh, can you close this out?
Yeah. This cut this out.
It still hasn't created see,
it still hasn't created the bot.
Yeah. So do this for me. On the left side.
Do you see the name David? Bottom at the very bottom?
Oh, yeah. Okay. Click on that one.
Click on the profile. Yeah.
Now click on the infrastructure on those tabs.
Do you see the infrastructure in the middle? Yeah.
Uh, let it load. Yeah,
definitely the bandwidth is having problem.
We can fix this ad.
It was, it was so fast Earlier.
Yeah, it was fast. Now, uh, slowly when people started,
uh, creating containers,
like the load started getting bigger and bigger,
and this series is happening.
Um, David, so once this is loaded, you'll see the same form
that you saw for the CloudFlare.
Fill that out. Okay. Connect it.
And once it's connected, uh, you can create the bot again,
and it won't have the same problem.
Okay. So, so this will take me through the steps
to create the bot and then connect CloudFlare.
Yeah. So what happens is, once this is loaded, you saw
that small popup for the CloudFlare, right?
With the form? Yeah. It's gonna load the
exact same thing down below.
Once it's stopped spinning
and you just fill up the values connect and it's done right?
Once there, it, it says the configure is done,
you can leave, leave this space.
Oh, Okay. And on the left side, yeah.
So this is screen. Just fill out the form.
Uh, you don't wanna share your screen while you're doing
this, but fill out the form, connect it,
and once it's connected on the left side, you see
that create your first claw, right?
Yeah. Yeah. Click on that one
and, uh, proceed with creating the
bot. And you should be good.
Alright, so, but
First, yeah, but first you gotta complete
that form and then connect.
Oh, I wanna complete this first. Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. Complete that step
and then do the one, uh, but you create the bot.
Oh, I, I thought you couldn't do this
until you created the, uh, bot.
Yeah, it's just so up previously.
But, uh, I guess we're having some problems.
So this is like a workaround for you, but do
This. Oh,
okay. Thanks guys. Okay.
You're welcome. We'll get you there. Okay.
Uh, Norman, you're up, buddy. What do you got going on?
Can you hear me? Yes, sir. How are you?
Okay, I gonna share the screen.
Sure. Okay.
Um, I'm here. I actually typed right here.
I asked that it looks like there was an error.
What, what's going on? And then it transformed it into this.
I have no idea what this means.
Oh, here it's, and,
um, mm-hmm.
Something here. I don't know. Is everything okay now or
Yeah. Is it still talking to
you? You'll always experience these
little errors and it'll fix itself and clear itself
and get used to this part, right?
When we do telegram, you won't see all this stuff,
but just tell me if it's still talking to you.
Yeah, try to talk to it.
I think I know the problem for this one,
it's probably cloud API it's rate limited or something.
Are you on tier two, Norman? What
Do you mean? Oh, okay. It's talking
to you.
So what you wanna do is, uh, I've installed your cloud.
API key. Let me, okay, let,
let me do the process you're doing, going
through the onboarding process right now, right?
Yeah. I like, I this part I didn't Well, yeah.
Uh,
Okay. Yeah. Now just
proceed with the onboarding. You're good.
Okay. Okay. I was everything. Follow
That video. Follow that
video, Norman. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Alright. Thank you. All
Right, buddy. Good.
One hand goes down. Yay.
All right. Uh, let me see.
I think we're on, uh, D or or Sam. Sam, uh, Courtney.
What you got, Sam?
Okay, let me share.
This is what I keep getting.
And I also noticed on the CloudFare page,
it's showing some red down at the bottom,
and it, it's got some a PII see in there.
I don't know what, where.
Uh, you don't have to worry about that CloudFare.
It's fine. That's normal error from CloudFare.
It gives us some time. Oh,
Okay. And, uh, okay,
well this, the reason
this, Catherine, okay,
Go ahead. Yeah, I see.
Okay.
Uh, did you already add your, uh, API key?
Yep. Okay. Uh, so it's saying disconnect.
Um, so
If you talk to it, it doesn't say anything.
It's definitely disconnected. Yeah,
It's disconnected. I
think the worker is down or something.
So, um, we can try to restart this one.
Can you go to AI engine and try to put your API key again
and save it just to restart the server?
Yeah, I can do that.
Yeah, just do that step. I think it use should be good.
One sec. You just want me
to replace the, the key, that's all?
Yeah, just replace the key it save and let it save.
Like, uh, wait for the message where it says it has saved,
and then go back to the chat.
It should work.
Okay. Hit saved.
Just got a green check. API key configured.
Okay. Now click on the chat.
It should be on the loading screen.
A YY geez.
Well, it's either gonna load
or go back to that same error message here.
Can we see it? It's, I'm, I've got a black screen.
Oh, I'm sorry. Did I, I didn't,
I I thought I was sharing my fault.
I had this happen too. Are you in Chrome?
I'm on, uh, comet. Basically, you know, ch I
Don't, but can you try Chrome?
Can you try Chrome or Firefox?
Um, Just try Chrome
and Firefox, see if you have a better experience.
Okay. I haven't used,
I'm gonna check back in with you again. I haven't
Used Chromin forever Or Firefox.
One of 'em, I don't know what common is,
but just try to use one
of the more common ones and see if the problem,
It's a chromium based browser.
Okay. Okay. I will check it out. Okay,
I'm gonna check back in with you.
Uh, Jordan, you were up. Where'd your hand go? Are you good?
Did you figure it out?
Jordan Ferrell? Did you figure it out?
Can you talk Jordan Ferrell?
Yeah. Hey, buddy. So did you figure it out?
I, I just really had a quick question,
but I I, it was about now, so once we have the bot hooked up
to our Telegram, it,
we can close the Claude Launcher, right?
We don't have to have that running all the time.
Correct? It is running all the time. It, it is.
As you're using Telegram, it's running,
but you don't have to be logging in hardly.
Yeah, it's just like your Facebook account.
You don't have to get logged in all the time.
Awesome. So now that I'm all set up, I can just go ahead
and close claw long term, unless there's Yep,
It's fine when you come back.
Awesome. Uh, it should be working.
And if you already have Telegram connected, you didn't even,
you didn't even have to open the site, just talk.
I completed all of that stuff. Yep. That's all. Yeah. What
Is, what what it's gonna do is it's gonna store all the
files and training and skills inside your CloudFlare.
Nice. Okay, cool.
But it does all that automatically.
You don't even have to know unless you want to.
Awesome. So you got it up and running?
Yeah, that was, that was the only question, uh,
that I had g covered everything repetitively
and that with Yeah, he's
Pretty awesome. Problems with pretty, yeah.
So that's perfect.
Okay, buddy, make sure you leave a comment. Yeah,
Absolutely. I'll go do that on
The wall. All right, Jordan.
Thank you. Alright,
Thanks. All
right. Uh, let's see.
Um, Marty, I think you're up Marty, and then James is next.
Marty, I'd be super surprised if you made it
through all those videos already.
Did you do that?
Uh, hold on a minute.
I don't know who just shared their screen,
so I'm gonna take it back for a minute.
Share screen. Okay.
Uh, Marty, can you unmute yourself?
Can you unmute himself? Okay. I guess not.
Uh, Amy, you're up.
Yeah, I saw that Josh, Amy, Amy
de hog. D Hogue. Yes.
Can you hear me? So I am going back and checking my R two
because I got,
um, I'm not sure.
Hold on here. Lemme check my screen.
Your screen, and then I actually have to find
where in the world I'm
Okay.
Can you see that? That's the error I got.
Can you see that or not? You cannot see my screen?
No, ma'am. Okay.
Um, I'm gonna come back to you.
I'm gonna go back and recheck my R two. Okay.
And then, um, I'll come back and see if that fixes it.
Okay, no problem. Thanks. Hey, uh,
Hey Chad. I'm
Rick. I'm with Marty.
Oh, hey, Marty. Where, who, who is this?
Uh, this is Rick. Uh, I, I'm with Marty.
I'm his, uh, virtual assistant.
So just asking if I can share my screen.
Yeah, I can't even find you though.
Are you speaking for him or?
Yeah, yeah, I am speaking for him. Um,
Like are you on his profile is what I'm asking?
Oh, no, no. I'm, uh, I am using different,
uh, account here. Uh, my name is
Okay, I see you now. I, I
I got you now. Okay. What do you got? Awesome.
So can you see my screen now?
Yes. So this is far, this is how far we, we get here.
So I did provide our API key for Claude,
and it seems like the assistant is not responding.
Okay, G I'll let you take over. Okay.
Can you say hi real quick? Let's see what's happening. Hi.
Um,
Okay, so as soon as you put in the
API key, it stopped working.
So maybe the API key could be wrong or something.
Oh, okay. Um, Um, is, is a solution.
Uh, also you said your API key on the call,
so you make sure it change that later,
but, uh, can you go back to the bot?
Okay. Oh yeah. And on the left side, you see that AI in
AI engine. I get it. This one?
Yeah. Yeah. And, uh, over there put the right API key,
like, uh, what I want you to do is, uh,
after you stop setting your screen, create a new API key,
delete the other one because you shared it in the call.
And, uh, put that new API key over there.
And once you save, yeah.
And, and then once you save it, when it says it's saved,
you can go back to the chat, it'll load and then talk to it.
And when it asks for API key, uh,
give it the exact same API key.
Oh, okay. Hold on. Let me, let me do it.
Well, on the call now, let me see if that works.
We're gonna let you do that. We're gonna check in
with you here in a minute, okay, Rick?
Okay? Sure. All right.
Okay. You wanna save? And, okay, it's saved now.
Yeah, you can go to the chat. Okay.
Yeah, let us know what happens.
Alright. Alright. I'll get back up to you guys. Thanks.
Okay, perfect. Uh, Ricardo, that's a good error.
So is it talking to you now?
Yes. It's, it's, uh, it seems so, yeah,
That, That was a good error.
Yeah, that's the, that's the first error you get
and it automatically pays for you.
That's the, that's how the system works. And you should be
Good. Yeah. Now it's
saying step one, cloud API key,
but it should be already there.
Yeah, if, if it's already there, you can just say skip.
I give it the A PIK again, it's your, it's your choice.
Okay. Okay.
Ricardo, I think you're off to the races, buddy.
Sorry, I said I think you're off to the races.
Okay. I think you're in good shape.
Make sure you leave a comment if you get it. Okay.
You are already done. Already done. Thank you.
Alright, thank you sir. Alright, so
Ricardo, pop in for a sec.
Who is it? This is Sam.
I just wanna pop in and say Chrome actually got me, uh,
running and got me to, uh,
here, so I guess now I'm good
to go, right? Yep.
You're good to go. You're talking, you can talk to it.
Say hi or something.
Just speak. Hello? Hi. No, I mean, on the chat
I'm Losing my mind a little bit.
Oh, man, it's, I needed, I needed a good laugh. That was
Funny. Yeah.
Thank you. You're welcome. Okay.
It's talking back to me.
It said, let me check where we are in your setup.
All right, buddy. Just say continue
onboarding. You're all set.
Yeah, you don't have to say anything.
You're, it is soft onboarding now. Don't say anything.
Yeah, sorry. So now you can give it the API key
or you can just skip because you already gave it.
Okay. What about the fact that I,
I love using perplexity comment browser,
but you think it's just not gonna work with that, or
It's a totally different, is this just temporary?
Yeah, I mean, we, we haven't, I, I know what you're,
you're getting at, but I mean, people are e are either going
with comment or they're going with this, right?
I choose to go with this from my experience, you know,
you gotta cite which one's best for you.
Yeah. I mean, common and come
and, uh, Chrome are, you know, they're pretty much the same.
You can download all kind
of chrome brow extension browser extensions to Comet. Um,
Yeah. But sometimes what
happens is, uh,
when you have a chromium based browser,
they create a new one, like RA or Comet, right?
There might be some dependency issues like, uh,
this site didn't load for you,
but this one works, right? So sometimes,
Right? Yeah. Well,
This works. So I'll
I'll use this.
Yeah, yeah. Let's use this.
I just wanna make sure I keep people focused on this
call, uh, Sam.
Yeah, because I don't want these people, right.
Go on to the next person. I'll continue on. Thank you.
All right. Thank buddy. Make
sure you leave a comment, okay?
Will do. All right. Thank you.
Uh, Jennifer, how you doing, Jennifer?
Let's check in and see if she figured it out.
Are you still struggling? Jennifer,
where is she at?
Can we unmute her? Jennifer. Jennifer Rodriguez.
Okay, we'll come back to her. Uh, Rick,
I'm done.
Rick. How we looking? Um, almost done.
It's still, uh, like still working on it, so, okay,
We'll check back in.
Yay. I'll, I'll keep, I'll keep checking in with you.
Uh, James, what do you got? Dan Wood. You're next. James.
Uh, Chad, here's what I got.
Um, I'm on the free account now
and I don't, I don't see where
you ha you can fund the $40 and, uh, share your
Screen. Share your screen.
Okay.
It's a good deal. Ricardo, please, uh, leave your comment.
Let him let him know. Update your comment.
I saw your first one. Let him know you got
it. If you would please.
Can you see the screen chat? No.
Let me, let me go back again.
I don't know what hap I I hit the button. Hold on.
Here we go. Let's go.
Uh, let me, I don't know what that is. Let me go back to,
You want me to come back to you till you
figure out how to share your screen?
No, I, I hit the share button.
Uh, yeah, come back, Chad. Let me see what's going on.
Okay, I'll come back to you. You might wanna
Google share your screen.
All right. Dan Wood. What's up buddy?
I was stuck to go into the call, tried
to go into the claw launcher,
and I thought I been wonderfully well.
And they came back and said, um, I've got one of the, one
of the keys was wrong and I couldn't set it up.
So I've tried to cancel it all and start again,
and it's still not doing it.
Okay. So I've gone back
through the videos while you've been doing your
thing for the last half an hour. Trying to find out. Can
You share your screen?
Yes. Um, I'm gonna share a screen. Share a screen, okay.
And,
uh, right there's me.
Yep. Okie dokey. And up here.
Oops, Stacy.
Okay, we're seeing
CloudFlare. Is that what we should be seeing?
That's what I got. Okay.
Yeah, that's just the wrong token.
Okay. So, um, Dan, can you go back to the screen? Yeah.
I clearly see that the value
that you have on the account ID is wrong.
That's not how the account ID looks like.
Ah, right. Yeah, that's what I've just been trying to do
for the last 10 minutes to find out my, my, uh, CloudFare,
I CloudFlare id, here's a CloudFare account.
Okay? So I can guide you real quick.
Uh, do you want me to do that?
Yes, please. Okay. Uh, where are you at right now?
Okay, on the left side, do you have that menu,
like big menu on the left side?
Scroll to the top? Yeah.
And down below where you see that story is in database.
Do you see that up above on the left side, you,
you'd see it down below
Storage and databases.
Yeah. Okay. Correct. Now click
on add to object stories.
Yeah. Now click an overview.
Right? And on the left side, do you see that account ID
Down Below? Down below, down
below. Keep go.
Uh, yeah, there just below. Just there.
Ah, that's my, here. Yeah. Do you see that account Id?
That's what you wanna put there.
Ah, right. Okey dokey. So I'll go into my thing here.
Oh, so you're saying everything on the call, by the way?
That's right. Right. So that's that one there. Yeah.
Yeah. That's what you wanna put in there
and, uh, make sure all the other values are right as well.
And once everything is right, you just should, uh,
you should be able to connect.
Okay. That's lovely. Thanks. I'll give that a go.
I'll catch you on the old, uh,
WhatsApp tomorrow if you, if I don't do it.
Okay, thanks Dan. Let us know. Okay.
Nice guys. Cheers.
All right. Bye-Bye. James, you got it.
It said somebody else was sharing the screen,
that's why you couldn't see it.
Okay. Hold on a minute. Share, stop. Share. Okay.
Uh, try it now, James.
Okay, let's go back.
Uh, Can you
See it? Credit are next.
And Jennifer, if you're around,
you're after Craig, can you see
It?
No. No.
And I know for a fact nobody's sharing their screen.
Okay. All right. I'm gonna come back to you.
You'll get it. I, I have, I have confidence in you, James.
I'm gonna log out and log back in and figure this out.
All right. Craig, what do you got? Okay, buddy,
You come back.
Um, mine did the weirdest thing.
I was set to go up running when I just preloaded my doc,
and as soon as I clicked it, it just disappeared.
And I mean, everything disappeared. I had
Like, out in the ozone, like in the universe,
just out there floating around in space. I have
To go back in and read everything from, uh, you know,
We'll come back. You'll
have to share your screen.
Get ready to share your screen. All right.
Jennifer, I called you once. You're up. How you
Doing? You did?
I was on my iPad and it froze.
I couldn't do anything, so, alright.
I'm stuck with I, I'm ready to put in my API, uh, Claude
Key, but I can't find it.
So I asked Claude, I asked Claude where to find it. Yeah.
And it, it showed me,
and then it has a button says create key.
So it's not something that's already created,
it's something I have to create.
Create, yes. Okay.
So you have to create it. You have to fund it at least $5.
Did that. Okay, good.
And then it makes it look like I have
to write in my own key.
No, you should just be able to copy it.
Yeah, you can just copy the, this would be a copy button.
I just select everything and copy
and makes it you save it somewhere
like not bad or something.
Okay. So it's on a default setting.
Yeah, that's fine. Let me help
You. This is my secret, key
and hit app. You see my screen right now,
Jennifer? Um,
let me expand it. I just,
So you're over here on API keys
and you're gonna click on this one.
It says Craig Key, right?
Ted, I, you hit on the screen,
I think you have Facebook up.
Share, share screen. Okay. Do you see it now?
Um, just the word. Oh, there we go. Okay.
So we're over here on API Keys. Okay.
And you click on Great Key. Okay.
And then you're gonna name your key. Okay.
And then once you name your key
and then pop up, it's gonna pop up
and you're gonna be able to copy your key.
Got it. Awesome. Does that, that's easy. Yep.
That helps a lot. Thank you so much.
Okay. You're welcome. Alright.
Um, okay, we're starting to get somewhere now.
Uh, Brian, you're next. Stuart, you're after Brian.
Then I'm gonna come back to Craig. Uh, hold on a minute.
Let me just check in. Uh, Rick,
you still got it? You still pushing?
Oh yeah, it's, uh, it's
Still going on. I
mean, it's taking, it's taking its time. Okay.
Uh, if that's the case, Rick, uh, uh,
did you already create a new key?
Like I told you?
Uh, yeah, I did.
Um, uh, in fact, I just reus
that same key. Does it
Matter? Okay. Don't, don't
reuse that.
Go, uh, create a new key and go to the AI settings
and then replace the key and then save it.
Okay. I'll do that.
Okay. We'll check back in with you.
Um, Brian, are you there?
Yep, I'm here. How's it going
today? I appreciate all help.
How, how you doing? Hey Chad.
I was doing really well, but then, um, yeah,
we're back on this screen again.
Uh, I was in Did the share come through?
Yes, sir. Okay. Uh, and it just spinning.
I was, I got into the, the, the bot it.
Um, I went through, started the, uh, the, um,
onboard process with it.
Yeah. I got through it partway twice and it kept rebooting
and then I forgot who I was both times.
The third time I said, you keep forgetting me.
And then it, we started the process again.
It said it updated the get file
and when we got to the telegram part,
I put that in and everything disconnected.
I couldn't figure it out, and then it crashed
and now it won't let me back in.
I don't even know what to say to all that. Do you, Eugene?
I know, it's just crazy.
Maybe it's the, the system is slow. I don't know.
I was in and everything, but
It was, you had it installed
and it was talking to Oh, yeah,
It was installed. I was
talking to it and I was doing through the, uh,
The And how are you going
through the install process again?
Well, it, you know, when you started it asked you, um,
you know, for your, your profile, it asked for your name
and I gave all that Yeah.
And went through it
and at, at a different point each time, two times it crashed
and then eventually I got back in again.
It forgot everything. I told it both times. Okay. And
Then the third time, I don't think I'll,
I'll shoot a video covering this for you guys,
but correct me if I'm wrong, g, once it's installed,
they shouldn't have to install it again.
Right. Even if it forgets the
memory or whatever else, right? No,
They don't have to install again,
but I think there's some problem
with the CloudFlare account or something.
Uh, so in this case, in this case, Brian,
what you can do is go to the server, delete this one
and create a new one.
Just do a new one. Start over again. Yeah.
And everything in again. Okay. Yeah.
So on the left side,
you know how to read this part, right? Yeah,
I can do that. Yeah. I go
through it again and create everything again.
Okay. Sounds good. Alright
Buddy, we're gonna check back in with you, okay?
All, yep. Stu Sutherland, are you feeling for me yet?
Yeah, I feel for, Yeah, me too. How's it going?
Uh, going well.
Okay. I just think it keeps, it keeps telling me it's, uh,
it comes up to, uh, tells me set up in, uh,
failed invalid CF token. What
Do you, what do you think? I'm gonna,
just
curious, what do you think I'm gonna ask you?
Uh, you're gonna ask me if I've checked all
these things and done?
No, I'm not gonna ask you nothing like that.
I'm gonna ask you, you to share your screen.
Oh, I was working on that already.
I was already heading that way.
Okay. Robert Huggins look like you're good. Hey,
If I have Claw launcher set up,
I'm now working on getting my claw API.
Okay, good. We'll check in with you in a minute. Okay.
Set up invalid token.
Okay. Invalid token.
Um, your API token down below.
Um, I think the CloudFlare ID is correct.
That's how it looks like.
But you might wanna double check that.
And your token is wrong.
Probably the API token that you have there is wrong.
Okay. Let's see here.
Oh, you're setting everything.
I've never seen somebody API call
API key shared on a call. Have you?
I didn't even think about it.
I'll redo 'em all, but yeah, if I get hooked up, I can redo.
I just went back and regot all of them
for both the CloudFlare and the uh, um,
and the anthropic and it's still not working for me.
So, um, here, let me,
let me just, uh, take this over to another screen altogether
where no one will see it.
There we go.
Do, do you wanna try to replace that on your own?
Go get those keys and try it again.
Yeah, I already have a couple of times
and it keeps doing this to me, so, okay. Um, show,
Show Me your cloud. Show
me your CloudFlare. I wanna see it for myself.
Okay. Go to storage. Over on left side. On the left side.
Storage and databases. Yep. Overview. Yep.
And there's your account id.
And then you're gonna click manage
to get the token right? Gee, if I remember,
Yeah, he already had the token up.
Uh, but let's try delete, delete this one.
Yeah, just delete the uh, top one where you have that.
Yeah, right here? Yeah. That one. Like
That? Yeah.
Type in the name
and create the account.
API token
three A A.
Okay. Uh, create the admin
And go down.
Yeah. Copy the, uh, you don't need that one.
That, that's token value. No, I need this one.
You need that Want? Yeah.
Go back to the site
and already have that I two access key down below.
Yeah, that one based in there.
Okay. And go back to the, no, don't do it yet.
Uh, go back to the CloudFlare again
because you create a new one.
The secret would be changed as well. Yeah. So copy that one.
Replace the last value.
Okay. Uh, did it replace?
Yeah, it should be. Okay.
Now try to connect, uh, in token. Okay.
Still. So where you see that CloudFlare API token, maybe
that's what we need to redo.
So go back to CloudFlare. That is fine.
That account is fine. I just checked your account as well.
Like on the top there's the value, right? So that's correct.
Um, got to your profile on the top right.
You know how to change all this, right?
Because you're sharing everything.
Yeah. Yeah. I've done done a couple times.
You just doesn't want to take,
Yeah. So on the left side you
have API tokens, right?
Right. Yeah. Click that one now. Create a token.
It's fine. You have other one, it's fine.
This create token, select the, um, template.
Edit, edit CloudFare worker. Yeah.
Now just, uh, go through this step.
Like include where you have the, include the first, include
select your account.
Second one, do all zone,
and then this continue to summary.
Yeah. Create a token. Yeah.
Now copy the value and paste that.
Not that one, the other one.
This one? Okay. Ah, that might be,
maybe that's probably less.
Not bad.
Not that one. The other one. This one? Yeah.
Yeah. Paste it over there. Now Connect.
Okay. So it's still giving you the same error. Uh,
Do you have all those things in a spreadsheet somewhere?
Or Notepad Stewart?
Oh, not, not the new ones we just created, but yeah.
Hmm. Went
through the whole process last night.
So when I'm doing it today, it's not wanting to like, um,
like when I go to, if I go to create one,
it's just going like skipping right past the
choose a plan and all that.
'cause I went through all that last night and chose plans
and paid for it. Um,
And You got It to work Steps
from last night.
You got it to work last night?
No, no. I, I didn't get it to this point,
but I had gone through and followed all the steps
to get all the numbers and stuff.
Un unless you do this, uh, the bot won't create,
because this is where you create the bot,
right? In the CloudFlare.
Right. Let him think on that for a minute.
Stuart, I'll come back to you. Okay.
No problem. No problem.
Okay, let's find a solution for that G if we can.
Yeah. Uh, Frank, what do you got?
Yeah, mine. Um, I had it talking,
then I installed the whisper key Uhhuh,
and then it's basically is we trying to connect it
and sa same picture as the last guy.
Can you share, show my screen.
They go blank. No, it's,
um, let's see.
Yeah, Sam, skip your browser install,
but I'm glad you're to that point.
Can you see it? Mm-hmm.
And this was after I installed my, um, whisper key,
Uh, installed your whisper key.
You mean you were going through the onboarding process?
Yes. And then when you is the whisper key point,
it gave you this error.
Yeah. Yeah. And um, first it said something about
disconnected for no reason.
Um, and I'm talking on that part.
I already put in my port profile or not. That one.
Think it took a snapshot of it. Oh, shoot.
I must have deleted it. Oh, well.
But it was at the, the browser part,
the open call part. And
Okay. Um, I think
you, you went
through the process in correct way,
but for some reason it's not coming back up, right?
Yeah. So do you see the restart button on the top right?
Yep. Yeah. Uh, can you try to click that one?
Okay. Yeah. It's not missing through. Okay.
Uh, this is not a problem with your key or any, any setup.
It can be trouble suited.
Um, what I'm gonna do
after this call is I'm gonna fix the, uh, few of the options
to go through the container.
And once you Okay. Uh, once I post all the updates, uh,
try clicking the restart button.
Once in a while, once I push
the update, everything should be there.
Okay? Yeah. And, and the alert thing, it,
it had this on in here.
Yeah, that's fine. Uh, it's an alert.
It doesn't have anything with the Okay. Real time.
All right. So just every once in a while click restart.
Yeah. Uh, I'll post the update for everything.
Uh, once you restart, it should be coming, coming back.
So, yeah, I was able to put my profile in.
And what's the other one? My other anthropic key.
It was working.
Yeah, I see the problem.
Yeah, we can, we'll be able to fix this.
All right. Uh, stop sharing.
Yeah. Okay. Let me just swing back around real fast.
Uh, Dave, did we get anywhere?
Dave, can you unmute yourself?
Hey, I was on my other screen. Um, nope. Still
Looping.
Okay. Same problem that we just saw now, G
Yeah. You went through
onboarding process once, right?
Hey, David, it's Aiden with Hatch. How's it going
Today? I'm fine. Who
are you with?
Uh, I'm with Hatch.
Uh, I saw that you requested a demo with us.
Does that ring a bell at all?
No, it doesn't ring a bell.
Um, I don't, I don't even know.
Where did you go? You didn't even have stand up.
All right, I'll come back. Um, FIAs, did we get anywhere?
FIAs, I can see him.
FIAs, can you hear me or no? Okay.
Manny.
Hey, can you hear me? Yeah. Did you get anywhere?
Yes. So, um, let me quickly share my screen.
Thank you for coming back. Um, okay. Share.
So let's make sure I'm sharing the right thing. Okay.
Just, I think I got, um, everything installed.
I just want someone to double check
because I'm, I'm going over your next, um, video.
I know it's for tomorrow, but I just wanna make sure the
setup is correct.
Yeah, I can see your per,
I can see it's asking for the personal profile.
So you're going through onboarding. You're good?
Yeah. Okay, good. It did ask me for my
API P, uh, again.
Uh, well, not again, but, um, and tr you know, um, so it,
and it said it was okay, so we are good, I guess. You're
Good. You are
good. Congrats. Leave a comment for me if you would.
Oh yeah, of course. That's, of course. That's no
Doubt. Alright, thanks. So
The next thing, I'll just watch a video
and then I'll wait for tomorrow's session
if anything comes up.
Thank you so much. Appreciate.
You're welcome. Thanks for hanging in there.
Uh, Rick, how are we looking?
Oh, yeah, there's progress.
Um, let me, can I share my screen? Yes, sir. All right.
All right. So there you have it.
So I did, uh, reinstall it and mm-hmm.
Uh, it seems like it's responding,
but I'm not sure if this is something.
Just say hello. Okay. Just say hello down there.
You'll always get these errors when we
get Marty on Telegram.
He will never see this stuff.
Oh, okay. There you go. You're all set, buddy.
Is it good? And, uh, yes sir.
What will be the next step, uh, from here?
Uh, you're onboarding.
He needs to go through the members area and
Start Yeah, it'll show you the new onboarding process.
So he scrolled through all the way to the bottom.
Mm-hmm. Okay. Um,
Okay. So it's saying great
news. Your cloud is installed. Okay.
Yeah. Just say what's next or something.
Uh, we'll go through the onboarding process tomorrow
probably, but you, you should be good.
Oh, okay. All right. Thanks though.
Um, yeah, I'm gonna put your,
I'm gonna put your hand down. Is that
okay? Yeah,
Sure, sure. Thanks.
Yeah, Marty, leave a comment.
Thanks a lot guys. Appreciate
The help. Can
you leave a comment for me, Marty? Sure. Thank you.
All right. Um, FZ,
I called on you a minute ago. How are you looking?
Yeah, I'm alright. I've been fasting all day, right?
And I've just eaten, so I'm feeling a bit, uh, a bit drowsy.
Okay, so I'm sharing my screen.
Is this done or have I missed something? Can
You say hello down there?
Uh, is it talking To you or no?
Um, it's just
saying nothing.
No. Okay. This is the problem with the API key.
The bot is fine, everything is fine.
The API key that you have entered there, it could be wrong
or it could be uh, not funded.
No, I funded it. 40, 44. $40 in there. Right.
So, uh, so where, where do I need go
to change the API key then?
Yeah, you go to the AI engine.
Ai, it's, it's ropy API key, right? Yeah. Uh,
Yeah. Okay.
So just place your API key down there
with the m empty spaces.
Yeah. Over there. And just save the settings.
Once it's saved, the bot will restart
and then you can go and talk to it.
Okay. Just gimme one second. Lemme do it.
I'll come off right. I shared them last time, right?
So I'll just quickly grab, um,
the correct DPI key because I changed it.
I did write. Okay. And I now have
it, uh, here.
So let me copy and paste it in. Okay.
Right. So I've got it here now.
Now I've got it now a second time.
So oh, oh, oh, maybe space, right? Copy.
Okay. So I'm gonna come in.
I'm not seeing your screen. It doesn't help us at all.
I think his listing his API key. So
It's api That's fine. Alright,
I'll check back in with you then. Okay.
Um, I'll post it in.
All right. Uh, Terry, you're up. How are we looking?
Terry? Still muted. We haven't got a hold of Terry.
Um, Sunol.
I can't even remember what we
were doing, but how are you looking?
Okay, I found the screen, but I didn't go any farther
'cause I didn't know how to do anything here.
Did you watch the videos in the members area?
No, not all of them.
I just got as far as this cloud flare and couldn't go any
Farther. Yeah, if you don't
watch those videos,
you're gonna be really, really lost.
Like, you cannot, I don't recommend anybody try
to figure this out on their own or try
to figure it out from a, a, a webinar, like
watch those videos and I think it'll
make it very, very easy for you.
Okay.
Okay. So is,
and was CloudFlare supposed to dump me in here?
Like I belong here.
They act like I have an account. I don't see,
It looks normal to me. I can
see your account in the top left corner now. You
Don't see. No, but I didn't
pay for anything. I didn't see you're not
Gonna pay, you won't, you won't pay cloudflare's free.
You won't pay until it's time to pay.
And you watch the videos, you'll see
where you're gonna sign up for that $5 subscription.
Okay. You'll, you'll watch the video. Alright, I'll
See tomorrow. I'll, I'll
go through all of 'em right now. Yeah,
Just, just make sure you do the videos
before you do the calls.
Right? The calls are kind of
to help you troubleshoot what you saw in the videos.
So try to go through the videos
and I think you'll be good. Okay.
All right. Thanks. All right, perfect. Um, all right.
Uh, let's see. Terry.
Okay, Brian, Brian, I'm circling back around
to you. Did we get anywhere yet?
I, is it Brian b or a different? Brian?
Brian. B Alright,
so I'm pretty much caught up.
I'm trying to get into, um, Claude
Con console and as well,
Hold on a minute. Did it, did
it install last time we saw
you was installing, right?
Yes. Can you share your
screen so we can see where you're at?
Uh, yep.
Can you see my screen?
Yes sir. That's definitely Claude.
So you can go to API keys.
Yeah. So I finally got here just
as we clicked in.
So, um, I'm following the, following the,
uh, training.
Yep. And, uh, okay.
I should be okay, but I'll,
I'll do this then I'll check
back with you guys here in a second.
Okay. Perfect. All right.
Um, Craig, you still out in the universe floating
around making stuff disappear? What are we doing?
Yeah, I'm still here.
I, uh, I think I figured out what the problem is,
but I need you guys to have a
share your screen at it and, uh,
Can you share your screen?
Yep. It's coming up. Okay. There we go.
I think the problem is it disappeared.
Yeah, you got too much going on. Hit,
Hit chat. Hold
on a second. See the one that says running?
Click on the one that's running
and hit chat for me for a minute.
Hit chat on the top left. Hit chat.
Is it talking to you here?
Yeah, it's already up. You just gotta say hi.
Say hi.
One with two accounts.
Mm-hmm. There, you're set.
Okay. So now how do I get rid
of the second account over here?
Yeah. Select that one. Click on that one.
Uh, click on the server down below. Uh, you went too far.
Yeah. Now scroll to the bottom. Now delete there.
Type in the name and the all caps
it delete and you should be good.
Now you see that there's only one now.
Yeah, I figured was,
I don't mind the troubleshooting. I love it.
All right. Well I don't, but I'm glad you do.
So make sure you leave a comment for me. Oh, yeah,
I got you. Alright,
take care folks.
All right. Um, let me see. Uh, James Coe, where are we at?
Did we figure out how to share the screen yet?
Um, if I hit the share button, which I did,
uh, what do you see? No,
Um, You should, when you hit the share button,
this should be a big popup coming up, right?
So you gotta select the screen, which you wanna send
It. It says choose
which share with, uh, your Zoom.
Yeah. So you can select your screen,
which you wanna say, uh, share with us.
Oh, okay. Okay. Gotcha. Well, that's what it did before.
Can you see it now, browser?
Not yet. Once you select, I think you,
you gotta hit the share button.
Don't,
Uh, I can't hear you.
There's like other people.
Okay, so, um,
Sorry Jean, you can talk now.
You're muted. Uh, James,
you're still muted.
Hey James, I'm gonna come back to you in a minute.
Uh, Wayne, can you talk?
Wayne Headley, can you talk?
Yeah, can you hear me?
Yeah, man, what's happening? Okay, it's
Kind of weird 'cause uh, I've got a new computer
and I don't, I'm trying to figure out the microphone on it.
But, um, when I went in
and, uh, opened up, um,
open claw, it was like,
it was already loaded on this, on this new computer.
I, which I've had actually for several months and shut down
and, and reopened.
Can you share your screen? Uh, yeah.
Lemme just a second.
If that was the case, that would be a scary thing.
Yeah, that would be a scary thing. Hold on.
Lemme just get over here.
Can you see my screen?
Mm-hmm. Okay, let's see where we're at. Here.
We're seeing the thank you page.
Okay. Seeing that going here.
See if I can get a couple of things here.
Um, so basically I was trying to get connected here.
Okay. So the URLU typed is going to Google.
So can you go to the browser?
Like, uh, the UL part on the top? Yeah. Type in app.
Do caller.io
App Do clauser.io.
That exact link.
That one? Yeah. The street. Enter
That work.
Yeah. Okay. It's not, uh, which browser?
You're in a right? I think it's a searching for you.
Oh, also the search engine is bing probably.
So it's just taking you, do you have another browser?
Uh, Doesn't you have Google website? You that
Google? No, we have Google Chrome. Yeah,
try it from that.
It is just, so doing the search for you,
not opening the link.
Okay. Yeah, just do that now. Type in the same thing.
App law, insert io.
Uh, you're missing law.
Oops, sorry.
And I think you mistype,
Did I?
Yeah, I did. What?
This is, this is vulnerable, isn't it?
Io Okay.
Yep. Now it return. Yeah. Oh, okay. Yeah,
There you're, now you can click on the sign up button
and then, uh, create your account.
Perfect. That was my problem.
Thank you, gentlemen. All right. Appreciate
It. Keep us posted. Okay.
Alright.
Will do. Thank you. Alright. Um, Chad? Yeah,
I'm back.
Did you figure it out? I, I, you couldn't hear me
before, so let's see if we can do the share screen.
I, I, it should work. I just have to push. You're
Part of my mastermind and you don't know how
to share a Zoom screen.
Do you know how bad that makes me look?
Look, I'm, I'm highly medicated with the codeine.
I don't even know what day of the week it is.
All right, fair enough.
Okay. I mean, this is not good stuff.
I guess not. Well share
Screen. Alright, now, now
it says here, um, it says choose
what I want to share.
So if I do this, do you see anything?
No. You gotta click it
and then click like the share button
again or something, right?
So like you click share once you choose
the screen that you're sharing.
And then there should be like a blue button
that says share down below.
There's a blue button that says share down below. Mm-hmm.
Okay. So I don't
See nothing.
I see the blue button down there, Chad.
And, and I clicked that and then I clicked, well
Try to explain what's the issue.
Oh, um, I don't see how
to fund the $40.
And the other part. And the other question is,
can I use my same, uh, Claude, uh,
I-P-A-A-P-I key that I used and, uh, Claude, um,
Can you see my Screen?
Can you my, see my screen?
Hold on, let me go back to you.
Uh, let me cancel this. Yes, I can see your screen. So we
Go to platform.claude.com.
Over here on the left hand side, it says manage. See it.
I don't see any of that on mine
Because you gotta go to platform.claude.com.
You're probably going to the regular one.
You gotta go to platform. I am,
I'm in the regular one.
Claude, uh, Chad, you're right. That ain't gonna
Work. That ain't gonna work. Okay.
You gotta go
to platform.cloud.com.
You go to manage, you go to API Keys, here's
where you're gonna get your API keys.
You click on billing, here's where you're gonna go
and, um, add your credit card and everything. Okay?
Yes. You're gonna do it from here.
This is just one of our many accounts. Okay. Does that help?
That's the answer that I didn't have.
So, um, that'll fund my cla.
Um, do I need a new API key for, um, 2.0 or not?
No. Use the same one. I can use the same one
that I used in, um, yeah.
Okay. So the only thing I need to do then is go ahead
and fund it, like you said, and I'm good.
Yes, sir. Okay, thanks.
Alright. Um, the end of the sharing screen dilemma.
Amy, did you get it figured out?
Amy? I think she's on a call.
Okay. Uh, so we're down to David, David Scarborough.
I'm gonna check in with you again.
Yeah, I'm here. It, I'll, I'll share my screen.
No, I did not get it. Uh, I,
I can tell by the tone of your voice
No.
Uh, what, what happened? Do you see my screen? Holy
Smokes. Look at that one. That's
a new one, G.
Yeah, I, Okay.
Uh, give me a minute, uh, to proceed.
That one, that one is just like,
gimme a screw you from left to right.
Gimme a second. Uh, um, okay.
Okay. So did you actually followed our step from the video?
Yeah, I, I put all the data in, I put all my
APIs in and Okay.
Uh, in there, there's one
Review. I, I,
I clicked, you know, do it and it came back
and said there was an error.
Yeah. So, so I just clicked it again. So
There's one more video at the end
and, uh, what that video shows you is
how to fund your worker.
Right? Did you do that?
Yeah. Okay.
And once you've, uh, funded the worker, Chad shows you
to create one worker.
Like you have to create one worker. Did you do that as well?
Create one? What? I'm not
One worker. Uh, if
you follow that video, Chad,
what Chad does is he pays for the $5
and then goes and create one worker. Did you do that part?
Yeah. Uh,
because the error says that you haven't done that.
Uh, can you, can you do
that right now? Do you have, do you have
I guess I'm, yeah,
I'm not understanding
what you're asking me. I apologize. Just
Open up, I'll walk you through it.
Open up CloudFlare Cloudflare's kind of screwy,
even though you pay the $5 you have to create this worker
to activate the plan,
even though we're not gonna use the worker.
Right? So on the, uh, uh,
left hand side, right?
G what's it under? Is it under Compute?
Yeah, it's, it's under compute. Click on that one.
Open Workers and pages. The first one? Yep.
Now on the top right, do you see, do you see that?
Create application? Yeah.
Now select, uh, start with Hello world
Select. Which one?
Uh, the green one. They start with Hello world. Yeah.
And now Deploy.
Yep. You're good. Now go to your, uh, uh, claw answer.
Now scroll to the bottom. Now connect
That pro that process was in the video.
Yeah. That process one was in the video as well.
It, it must, okay.
I must not have watched that video because I got my API keys
and I never, I never saw that, uh, to do that.
Oh God.
Okay. Um,
uh, scroll to the bottom.
Okay. Since you just created it, uh, I think you should, uh,
redo the step from the beginning.
Like, rephrase the pace and re re uh, input the values.
Like, don't try to connect right now. Oh, you, I'm sorry.
Yeah, so it's probably because of that,
because you just created it, right?
And there's probably casting and it didn't go through.
Okay. So, so wait till what?
Another 3, 4, 5 minutes or hour or,
Uh, just rephrase it
and then, uh, try to put in the values again.
You see it's saying that, that there's cast,
everything is casted, so it's, it's not working for you.
Okay. So yeah, that's the reason.
So just, uh, I think you can just rephrase the pace.
Do control r or you can do that too.
And, and input, input the values
again, and then try to connect.
I think it should go through. Okay.
If not, then try to log out and log in.
This should be casting issue.
Okay. All right. You can come back to me.
I have a, I have a feeling
that's gonna be your issue, Dave.
Okay. I hope so. No, we'll get it. All right.
Um, uh, Linda,
I think you're a new issue for us.
Yeah. What do you got?
Can you hear me?
Yes, I hear you. What ha what problem are you having?
Uh, it took me a while.
It took like 10, 12 times to get past the part, uh,
in the claw launcher for the plan to select the plan.
For some reason it just wouldn't take it.
And then all of a sudden it did take it. Okay.
And I finally got into it, got me into the chat,
but I've put in just silly questions and stuff
and all it's doing is it's got a, it comes back
with assistant A just says a, that's it.
But no matter what I ask it
Because Did you fund your API key or your AI key? That,
That's what I was trying to find was
where if there was billing on, on the open claw side,
It, it, there, there's no billing on the open claw side.
There's billing on the Anthropic side on Claude.
So if you go to platform.claude.com, you probably need
to put at least $5 on there for it to start talking.
Okay. Does that make sense?
Can you try to do that and I'll come back to you?
Lemme get that, see if that'll work.
Okay. We'll come back to you.
Um, Terry, are you around?
Terry Huckabee? I'm trying to get your help, but,
Uh, Chad, I'm still here.
Right? And I know you passed on to Terry there,
but, um, I did the same thing.
Right? And it's still not working right.
And, uh, I've been kind
of waiting you a half an hour. I know you've gone around the rounds.
Share screen again. Share screen again.
Was this the, um, the bandwidth issued?
I put Yeah, no, I put the, I put the key in straight away.
Right. But I still got the same thing.
I re-put the key in and I still getting just this.
And you funded it?
Yes. I'll just check my bank account. Right.
It's been, uh, deducted from there.
Did you create a new API key?
Um, yes.
I went back again recreated
and then, uh, did, did it again. Where
Does you need to look for the sg?
Um, okay, so this is definitely the AI API problem,
the configuration problem with the API
that's not responding.
Mm-hmm. Um,
you already did the AI engine thing, right?
Um, yes. This thing. Yeah. Yeah.
You added the new API key that you created?
Yes. Okay.
And, uh, which model did you select over there?
You did the SONET 4.5, right?
Yeah, SONET 4.5.
Okay. Yeah, so everything should be fine with you. Yeah.
So, uh, the thing I talked about earlier
where you can rephrase this
and then fix the issue, I gotta work on that.
So yeah, look, look out for that one.
You should be able to fix this.
Like, we'll troubleshoot this and let you know.
What do you want me to do? Do you want me to reset?
Do you want me to start again? Do you want me to delete this
and then connect it again?
Um, you can try to delete
and connect it again if you want,
but what I'm saying is, uh,
we gotta work on that, uh, troubleshoot.
So what I'll do is I'll push an update
after this call once I do the fixes,
and you should try to restart on the
top. There's restart, right?
Yeah. Uh, restart. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. So that, that's not working right now
because, uh, it's not pushing the
configuration, but I'll fix that.
Uh, fix all those sensors and then push the update.
Try to do that. If not, uh, if you want, you can try
to recreate this and it should work.
Okay. So if I need to
delete it, where do I delete
it from? I have to start again.
Uh, you would go to the solver down below.
You see the solver option?
Yeah. Yeah. And you scroll to the bottom.
Yeah. Yeah. There's the delete button
That will restart again. Yeah.
If you delete, uh, you just create another bot.
You don't have to input the CloudFlare
again because you already did.
Yeah. So you can just delete this
one and create another bot.
Okay. So I, I, I have to put, uh, I have
to type this to delete it.
Yeah, you can just copy the, it takes,
uh, as well. Delete. Yeah,
I'm back to square one. Yeah.
Square. Yeah. So now you can create a bot, continue
with the process and input your API key
and then see what happens.
You know, the, the previous process
right before this, right?
Which was, uh, create your flaw first.
Don't only, don't I need to do that first?
No, that's only one time thing.
Okay. And if, if at the point of connection it's, uh,
it seemed to say, uh, not connected
to your CloudFare account,
and then it seemed to just go into the chat, right?
So it did come up with something
that said not connected, and then it went into,
Oh, okay. So that's, that's
the default of OpenCL.
When you saw that screen, I think you saw disconnected
and it said, I guess probably the pairing
or something issue, and then it worked, right?
Yeah. So that's the normal process.
It happens, it's configuring on the backend,
and as soon as it's complete, uh, everything starts working.
Okay. So you just want to do exactly the same again? Yeah.
Go through the same process, see if it, uh, comes back.
And then if not, I'm already pushing the update.
So you should be good. Uh, probably tomorrow on the call.
If you have any problem, let us know.
Okay. So this is fine.
I've just gotta put the key here and then, uh, yeah.
Do you want me to create a new key?
Yeah. Uh, I'll also assist you to create a new key. Yeah.
Alright. Okay, fine. Okay, fine. Find no issues.
Let me do that. No problem.
Okay, we'll check back in. Uh, Dave?
Yes, sir. How are we looking?
Not good. I, I didn't,
didn't remember seeing anything about creating a worker.
Can you walk through that? I got lost when he uh,
No, I need you to go through the members area to find it.
It's there. It's clearly there
because that's how everybody was able
to do it today, right?
Like, you guys gotta go through the members area.
Like I could share where it's at on the screen,
but I'm not gonna walk through the whole thing again.
If you look over here, uh, if we come to the very,
very beginning, everybody's account the same blue, right?
You open this up and see what it says.
Set up your worker. It's right here.
I I paid the $5. I did that.
Yeah, but you gotta watch the whole video, man.
Watch the whole video I show you to set up that worker.
I even tell you, you can delete it.
It's there, it's there. You gotta watch a
Video. I did, I
did go through it. I just don't remember.
That's all.
But if you don't do that part, it won't work.
So go back through, like somebody said earlier,
pause it, see what you can do with it.
Yeah. All right.
Uh, Norman,
did we get anywhere?
Yeah. Yeah, I'm here.
Uh, it's like, it's, it's working,
but then the, the chat just goes online
and offline, like sporadically. You
Wanna share your screen?
We'll cover all this tomorrow with actually dealing
with the a ai, the APIs, the ais, the,
the onboarding, all that stuff.
Today we were just trying to get, uh,
a claw launcher installed, which you did.
So
Spell It, say hello to it.
Yeah, it's like, I, I did the chat a bunch of times
and I just, it won't, like I did.
You can see my messages up here.
Are you on tier two for your API key?
Uh, I paid, uh, like 10 bucks
to Claude, if that's what you mean.
Okay. So it's wanting to set up the memory,
right, Jennifer?
Got it. Good. Jennifer. That's great.
See where it says new message there.
See, you gotta learn at the bottom there's a
little thing that says new message.
I cannot wait to get you in Telegram
so you can get past all this.
'cause it's confusing. You see? Now look.
New message, click it. There you go. That make more sense.
Uh, I am in Telegram,
but I was getting, um,
I was getting this even though like, I ha I paid, you know,
There's, oh, okay.
Yeah. So this is the problem with Claude.
Like once you talk for, uh, talk to talk with it
for a minute or something like that, uh, yeah,
you already is the token value, right?
So, uh, we are gonna bring, bring the kimmi
and then, uh, any other model that you can use.
But right now we only have,
and if you wanna use this, uh, something,
Lemme know when you're ready.
Okay?
On. Yeah. So, uh,
Go ahead Jay, talk again.
Oh yeah. Okay. Uh, so yeah,
we are gonna bring other models that you don't have to like,
uh, keep paying like this, doing $40
and stuff like that, right?
But for now, Claude is, uh, always asking for tier two.
So if you can try to find $40 over there
and it'll upgrade your rate, rate limit.
That makes sense. Norman?
No, I think he's muted as well.
Norman?
Yeah. Uh, I have to wait for the kimmi. Uh,
Yeah, for now, for now. Try
to complete that onboarding process.
You have the telegram connected, right?
So it's talking to you on the telegram as well.
And later on we'll bring the kimmi like, pretty soon,
probably this week, like not even the end of this week.
I'll work on that.
And you'll have the open router, you'll have the kimmi
and a bunch of stuff, so it'll be a lot easier.
Well, I like, I noticed like when I chat with it, it like,
it just goes offline.
Just like it, it'll like, gimme
Like a, okay, so, so that's something with CloudFlare.
Uh, what CloudFlare does is, uh, if you're not talking
to it, like you stop talking to it, the bot goes offline,
but as soon as you talk to it, it comes online.
Yeah. You want that because if it goes offline,
that means it's not billing you for anything.
Yeah. It doesn't bill if you, if it goes offline,
that's the feature of CloudFlare.
Okay. And then like a couple times I noticed
that it said health, like disconnected over here.
Yeah. We'll cover all this stuff. Norman.
I don't wanna confuse people right now,
but we'll cover all this stuff, but you're installed,
Okay? Okay.
You are good. Alright, thank you Norman.
Um, so gotta go Chad. Such an amazing patient process. Good.
Uh, I saw that Stu settling got set up.
I saw somebody else got set up.
Uh, Arlene, uh, what issue are you having?
I was set up, um, and now I'll share my screen.
I'm having it, there's something to do with the server,
a worker, API maxed out or something.
Here, let me share my screen here.
Great. Can you see that?
Oh, okay. Uh, work. API maxed out.
Okay, so this bot is having problem.
Um, this is the first bot you created, right?
Uh, is this the first? Yeah. Yes. Okay.
Uh, I think it, uh, ran into problem, uh,
with the container on your Cloudware account.
Um, okay. The simple solution is just scroll to the bottom.
Okay. Delete the bot and create a new one.
Have you already done that?
Um, I did it, yeah, I did it once,
but then I realized, uh, I, the one I went
to delete didn't completely delete.
I saw that when you did the dropdown. Yeah.
Um, okay, so if,
and if this doesn't work,
is there something in CloudFlare I'm to, I should do?
No, you, you don't have
to do anything on CloudFlare, but it should work.
If it doesn't, uh, I'm already saying
that I'm gonna push updates with this one.
Okay. Like, it would be a lot
easier to troubleshoot after that.
Okay. Awesome. Thank you.
Alright. Um,
so David, anything,
I'm going through the whole process all over again.
I, I got the workflow.
I paid the five bucks, um,
and it just keeps coming back with air.
So I shut it all down
and when I got back into it, it said there's no bot.
So now I'm trying to create the bot again.
Okay. Well come back to me, come back to me.
Uh, let me, let me go through and see what happens
and you can come back.
I think what I'll do is I'll reach out
to you when he has that update pushed.
I think that'll make a big difference. Yeah. So
I had some progress here.
Chad.
What's that? I had some progress here, so,
but uh, can I just share a screen with you?
Sure. I'll repo the, uh, key and,
and, uh, this time round.
Okay. So, um, I said hello, came in, it started,
asked me to put my key in
and then it's gone to this kind of chat.
Is this what I'm expecting?
Yeah, that's the onboarding. Okay.
Uh, that's the onboarding, but uh,
It looks like he's already gone through it, right?
Yeah. Okay. Hello you and then it started.
Okay. Uh, do this for me. Uh,
can you click on the new chat, new message down below
where it says new messes at the very bottom of the chat
where you, where you type the chat,
there's new messes on the top.
Yeah. And now say, uh,
can you start onboarding from the beginning?
It asked me to put my API key in.
Is it supposed to do that?
Yeah. Uh, but you can simply say skip
because we already did that, right?
It was a process for the PS we did previously,
but since this one, uh, we didn't have to do that.
Yeah. So you can just say, yeah,
you can just say, I already did that.
So just say skip. It's fine.
Yeah, you're good. You, you have it installed.
We're gonna cover onboarding tomorrow. Okay. FIAs
Fine. Fantastic. Okay.
Thank you. Thank you guys.
All right. You're welcome. Make sure you comment.
Uh, Linda, did you find it?
Linda, are you able
to, did you find it?
Yeah, I got it. I'm in the, trying
to get signed up for the sign up.
Uh, pay for the card stuff now.
Okay, perfect. Thanks. Alright, you're welcome.
Um, guys, I'm gonna tell you something man. I'm exhausted.
I knew it was gonna be a challenge, um,
but it's a good challenge.
I know the problems that we had, what we ran up against.
I'll shoot the little tutorial videos to try
to fix as much as we can.
I'll meet with G and the,
and the team to see what we can do to solve a lot
of these problems and, and kind of automate things and,
and, uh, we'll, we'll fix a lot of that stuff.
But it was a, um, you know, first time, you know,
taking a crack at this and seeing how he did.
And you heard g say that he didn't know what to, he didn't,
he didn't know that I was gonna bombard him today
with 150 people trying to get all installed at once, right?
But the people that did comment that they were good.
Uh, this is pretty amazing.
Like 40 people commented, uh, so far.
Most of 'em said they did have it right.
I know Ricardo definitely got it before he left the call.
So this is good.
I'm just gonna go ahead and put this
in the chat one more time.
It's important that, uh, uh, we get, uh,
your guys' response on this stuff.
So please, please, please leave a comment down below.
Even if you want to say we hung out for four freaking hours
to help as many people as we can, that's great too.
Um, the rest of the calls will not go this way.
I imagine tomorrow with the onboarding is
gonna be pretty simplified.
We're gonna have some really,
really good updates for you guys today.
Uh, we're gonna work on it
and, uh, moving forward there won't be as many issues.
Okay? There just, there won't.
Uh, I went through it the first time too.
Um, with, uh, the first workshop they started smoothing out,
uh, the calls will start going into strategy,
training skills, stuff like that.
So, uh, if you didn't leave your comment,
please, please, please, please.
It's important to me that you leave your comment over here.
Um, 'cause we want to show everybody
that we're taking care of you guys. All right?
Can you give it, can you give us the link
to the comment again?
Yeah, just, I just put it in the chat.
I just put it in the chat so there's still, I don't know,
like 75 people on the call.
So guys, it would be great if you
commented like whatever the case is so
that everybody can see this.
Um, and like I said, the process will get better.
We'll this is how it works every time, right?
We always, we always take a, a beating up front
and then, uh, you know, we start figuring things out.
And so there's still three hours left in the day.
I'll work with the team, we'll be
ready for you guys tomorrow.
And yeah, uh, for me it was a huge success.
I think G and Pade did a great job on this tool
and, uh, if you guys understood the difference between this
and the VPS, you'd really, really appreciate it
and we'll get these issues fixed.
We'll work on it and uh, we'll meet same time tomorrow,
10:00 AM Pacific Standard Time
and uh, we'll do everything we can to help you guys.
Alright? So we'll put the replay in the members area.
Thank you. Thank you, thank you. I appreciate it, Josh.
Gimme some time to work on that.
I gotta figure some stuff out. Okay.
Um, but yeah, on that note guys, I'm gonna conclude it
and we will see you guys tomorrow.
Alright, bye everybody.